you picked her up friday you're living
over there like a doctor you have to get
the robe yet
no we're gonna hit the road i'm waiting
what are you walking around you're with
boxing shirts those [ __ ] little
things you wear with your big [ __ ]
feet with no socks on
yeah the mom bought me sandals this
weekend did she really yeah i love this
she came back she gave it she bought the
whole family one of those mexican
sandwiches they make it over there from
tijuana all the way to san diego does it
yep she made me tacos this weekend
homemade tortillas how many did you
throw them only four
calories
i don't know how many uh those are
to be honest but not much it's only
carne asada and put them in the fitness
book uh not now we had a little bit of a
cheat weekend
all right what else has happened where
you've been you went to the [ __ ] we
went to oddball which is very fun i saw
a bunch of people there were very nice
um people recognize your life yeah there
were a couple cool people there sure
because i mean they always go see you in
irvine all right uh yeah it was a lot of
fun it was a great weekend it was
[ __ ] hot but yeah had a good time
without yeah it was a lot of fun it was
uh i've never been to like an outdoor
comedy show
and a bunch of people did really good
so it was a lot of fun it was different
though
yeah it was it's more impersonal like
it's
even a 100 tickets you're 30 [ __ ] 40
yards away more than that more than that
right yeah it was we were in like the
loge area um
but it was fun it was just i really like
comedy shows because like it's it's kind
of like the difference between watching
it on tv and watching it in a club like
the entire club is supposed to be
laughing but with 15 000 people
seven and a half thousand aren't paying
attention
and some of them are going to get drinks
there's a baby in front of us and like
every time i see every time i'm anywhere
i think of stuff like what you would say
and the baby was fine it didn't cry or
anything but i'm like i kept thinking of
what you say about like how you how
you're raising your daughter i'm like
get a babysitter or don't come because
the mom spent half the thing walking
around with them
what's the [ __ ] use what if what if
the [ __ ] gunman goes crazy starts
shooting people you brought your [ __ ]
baby like batman when the guy brought
the [ __ ] baby to batman midnight
viewing why would you bring your [ __ ]
baby to batman there's no relatives you
can't wait till tomorrow is he [ __ ]
batman
you know that's what i'm talking about
how's that eleanor carrick in the
[ __ ] weigh in on this this
that's crazy that's why you refer to the
baby is it don't do that don't do that
that's rude to me
i'm sorry all baby listeners they
brought it
so well it was just i felt so bad it was
a cute baby we were like we're messing
around with the shoe yeah before the
show but but joey's right they're all
cute until somebody starts [ __ ]
shooting shoot you know listen i'm not
saying people are going to shoot you
saying joy why you saying that this is
your child you know
when i was married 20 years ago she had
to [ __ ] bug up her ass to go see
pretty women
me from a consumer side when i sit
somewhere and a baby starts crying
i get agitated so
here i have a baby now who the [ __ ] am i
to bring this baby to the movie thing 10
minutes in whether richard gear's on
stage or the other pretty [ __ ] the baby
started crying i got to get up and walk
outside yeah it defeats the purpose it's
the law diminishing returns you know
what i'll stay home and watch the baby
go see [ __ ] pretty women and that's
how i feel about all those things you
know if you're gonna fly with a [ __ ]
baby guess what
people want to sleep at night when they
take a red eye don't show up with 22
[ __ ] kids at night crying yeah people
want to [ __ ] sleep man yeah you know
it's just little courtesy things you
want to fly with your baby get on that
[ __ ] at six in the morning then
i'm i can't get mad at you yeah there's
little [ __ ] things a nice restaurant
really you gotta bring your child a
comedy show it's that important to you
to see [ __ ] sarah silverman that you
gotta bring your [ __ ] baby language
it's not even that the baby's half
[ __ ] he's there in his [ __ ] coma
yeah you know my daughter's 20 months
what the [ __ ] does she know what louis
ck is saying or what sarah silva saying
she's just sitting there with her head
looking around going why can't i [ __ ]
run and how old was the baby baby less
than six months yeah it was a baby
and it's kind of crazy because i i'm
interested to see what two comics have
to say about it and i had a great time
the show was mostly great but there were
a few people there where it was like
if there was like a if like if like
let's say comedy central made a list of
top 10 comics they'd be on it and you're
supposed to like them but they didn't do
well
and like you two weren't there there
were comics who could have been there
for a lot less money and our tickets
would have been less but it was like
if you're a fan like a generic fan of
comedy would think those were the best
people and not that dan cook isn't funny
but i called my mom and told her about
the show she's like oh is dan cook there
it's like stuff like my mom is going to
think those comics should be that cook
wasn't that why it's because you're jane
cook wasn't the other night yeah well
yeah she loves dance isn't he the
president of massachusetts he used to be
oh you're dead no didn't come out oh i
saw it i saw a picture of your dad with
a club
yeah science
that wasn't that wasn't his club he he
worked in nightclubs for like 25 years
he did like promotions and [ __ ] he
didn't even singles parties he oh he uh
right before online dating came out and
killed it but is he is he the one that's
in that picture that says science yes
high heels and [ __ ] he had high heels on
you could tell that [ __ ] but
they're all short yeah you could tell
that [ __ ] had a grandma blowing
his pocket oh yeah you could tell that
[ __ ] was the real guy how can
you tell what did he he said yeah just
you could just tell he had that outfit
on on a tuesday night yeah you wouldn't
put your [ __ ] suit on like those big
front pockets yeah it was it was like
yeah right
or maybe early 90s but he was he was on
radio and and that stuff for 20 years so
it must be he must have
what's up with you
jacket with patches on his elbow no
patches oh no patches but he's always
smiling the huge glasses huge huge jew
from
always a pleasure to see eleanor kerry
and i bumped into it the laugh factory i
like getting women on the show i like
women's perspective on comedy i like
women's perspective on life but it's
just too tough to find women
that'll come in on a monday night they
get offended the language reefer smoke
lee you know
it's all different things i know nothing
offends you i've known you now for 17
years and uh i don't yeah i don't know
if i'm
i have the ability to get offended is
that anything yeah at this point there's
nothing really we've seen a lot of faces
come and go together way too many i went
to the store last week two weeks ago
yeah you've been back it's amazing yeah
who came running out to me but katie
and i gave her a hug
and i thought of all the fun nights i
had like when she came to the store i
really put the east
coast into perspective like when you
grow up in the east coast there's always
like five or six people that put that
neighborhood into the [ __ ]
perspective yeah they go to every party
ruin it
you know christmases ruin it perfect
[ __ ] bars ruining it yes and katie
was that person always i loved her
i loved the depth i loved her balls uh i
loved the fact that she was irish and
she had a nice ass and she had buck
teeth and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
the first night she worked well not the
first night but the first week i think
it was christmas they hired her right
before christmas and she worked new
year's eve in the belly room it was a
private party for paulie shore she was
working some girl was drunk and stealing
her tit money
so she comes down
[ __ ] wasted midshift and she's got
blood all over her knuckles and i go
what happened she goes i guess i'm fired
i [ __ ] up this girl upstairs she was
taking money out of my tip jar elena so
i'm [ __ ] out of here and she just
left and i'm like
uh what it was paulie's assistant and i
was like you're not fired i'm giving you
a
that's hysterical i remember one night
she chased a dude
peter chad she chased the dude up a
parking lot oh yes you know that parking
lot next to the comedy street to get a
run uphill yeah some dude and her were
arguing and she was the bottom of the
hill and she kept a [ __ ] you
[ __ ] she was drunk
and one thing led to the other she
kicked out of the shoe off and she ran
up and tackled them didn't she pan
someone took his pants
[ __ ] hilarious he's the real deal
they don't make them like normal it's
just nice to see yeah
all those people again i was telling my
wife my wife goes so how's it been at
the store you know my wife was a
waitress at the store
i told her eleanor was going to be
honest and she goes i don't know i was
the first person that knew we were
dating i don't know busting this at
ralph's
at two in the morning and i was fighting
with her because she used to get
margarine and i used to that was why are
you doing that i can understand that
cause i used to go what [ __ ] person
gets margaret i never met nobody only
you would get in a fight about butter
versus oh my god who eats [ __ ]
laundry i know i agree like [ __ ]
martians eat [ __ ] margaery does she
now not eat margaritas oh no she won't
even dare bring that [ __ ] tonight
but i'll never forget that he said to
her so you guys live in things and she
goes i don't know yeah he just showed up
one night with a bag that's it that's
[ __ ] crazy
terry's a great terrific terrific person
well yeah it must be hard to get
offended because not only are you a
comic but you were a waitress at a
comedy club and she has nine [ __ ]
brothers brothers i have six brothers
and sisters so nine brothers and sisters
or something like that oh yeah you don't
get offended when you get hand-me-downs
and punches you know you wanna fight in
your face yeah they make you come in the
bathroom they show you a piece of [ __ ]
always you know yeah that's what guys do
to their sisters man yeah my brother
johnny's the worst he's like come on
look at this one i had to stand up to
finish it the [ __ ] is wrong well they
don't even say no you can't hurry up
they suck in the bathroom and they lock
you in the bathroom that's why all these
girls are tougher than [ __ ] nails
they had brothers around them that
tackled them you know when they were i
shared a room with them there was there
was eight of us in one or seven of us in
one room how we had a triple bunk bed
and then i had a mattress that pulled
out underneath and then we had a double
bunk bed and a single bed my brother
tommy tommy
johnny charlie jimmy
bobby billy me
holy
so like i was getting hit with stiff
socks every 30 seconds it was a mess but
i didn't mind sold six boys and three
girls yeah but my sisters were like ten
and nine years older like karen and
kathleen
karen's ten years kathleen was nine
years and they were at that age where
they were like [ __ ] her i don't want her
in our bed you know so they kicked me
out and the boys were like yeah come in
here so i was like
hey
no one wanted to molest me or anything
it was really upsetting
[ __ ] nine six brothers that's a i
remember dating irish girls that was the
most complicated family system
ever really because i feel like we're
like
easy i mean they're crazy not
complicated but in a sense that it's so
like i dated this girl and she's on
facebook now
and i see her on facebook i dated it for
maybe three months
and i
uh i kind of cheated on it i was a
sophomore junior in high school i kind
of cheated on it you know we were
swapping spit i was sucking the titties
in the winter but nothing really
happened you know what i'm saying she
let you suck
out
and she had great tits a girl i had a
great body that hit it wow and she was
so catholic
with the three sisters and the four
gorilla brothers she'd let you feel her
up a lot no there was no [ __ ] there was
no ass there was nothing you know i
would be sucking her tits and i'd go the
finger and she'd like no
so there was a different girl that let
me finger her you know do crazy [ __ ] and
i cheated on this girl stopped talking
to me and we spoke years later and she
told me she goes i still have your black
sabbath volume four eight track i bought
you for christmas she goes i refuse to
give it to anybody else if you want like
why would i want a [ __ ] 8-track yeah
like i saw 10 years later and we talked
like friends
and she's on facebook now does three
sisters still do [ __ ] together
it's my family they married guys that
all knew each other oh wow so friday
saturday and sunday they're on down the
street and they put the pictures up
you know they put the pictures up with
them down seaside philadelphia yeah they
go away together kids go to school
together and you look at it as
i don't know some people might look at
it as [ __ ]
i wish i had something yeah that's such
a great community i had six people to go
away with
and i could just leave my kids with i
don't know and sailing yeah drop your
daughter next week but did you get along
as kids or was it oh yeah i mean we
fought because we're irish we did we
were on top of each other we were in a
south philly row home so it's tiny oh my
god so even our room was like t90 like
no one was ever allowed upstairs my
mother was like people can come in
announced only no unannounced [ __ ]
because the place could be
turned upside down you know like and
then if like the priest would knock on
the door my mom would freak out she'd be
like hey everybody pick something up
like just should we get nervous you
don't want the priest to see what slobs
we could be it's amazing when you're
irish the priest comes to your house
once a week oh my god he eats dinner
just knocking looking for money we need
a roof i remember the one priest my mom
gets mad when i talk about this but he
was like we need money for a new roof
i'm like i'm sleeping with [ __ ] pots
under my arms in my
really we need a new roof we don't have
any money either but they would they
didn't care they would keep calming
and my mom would give them the money
when i first moved from new york city to
jersey
i was friends with a lot of different
families but there was one italian
family i was really tight with i went
over there
him and i had fought and after that
fight we became oh that's such a kid
thing and the other day i was talking to
the older brother and the older brother
doesn't talk to him or the rest of the
family no more
and we were just talking about general
[ __ ] he goes you know what they don't
even do wednesdays no more
they haven't done pasta wednesdays after
the house in 20 years
and as i was he was telling me they
don't do it anymore
i got this coldness in my body because i
was a cuban kid i lived with my mom and
my stepdad
we very rarely ate dinner together you
know i wanted to be a walton kid i
admired what these people did yeah like
my mother had money i had my own air
conditioner i had my own cable box my
own tv in my room carpeting my own
bathroom
but i would give it all up
to have three brothers to jump around at
night like steve simone talks about it
oh yeah yeah and all that [ __ ] and he
had that
my friend john had that on wednesdays
and it's amazing on wednesdays you go to
his house after school
and there'd be a pot of pasta yeah in
the middle
right and you just scoop it and then
there'll be sauce on the stove with the
meat and everything
and i ate so much that the mother would
go you know i roll those meatballs with
my feet
and i would think about like she [ __ ]
hated me the mother but the father loved
me the sister loved me the boys loved me
so the mother had to put on me but i
told him as i go i still remember want
something obvious that 20 feet from the
stove your sister would be cutting hair
at the time she used to cut air at a
hair salon but on wednesday she cut
everything in the neighborhood of the
disneyland sister carrington so if it
was 20 bucks yeah in the kitchen
so here you get you're eating spaghetti
oh yeah 20 feet away and not one [ __ ]
person with hay there's hair we're going
to be in my food you just accepted it
when i told him that the other day
he was dying of laughter and crying at
the same time because the tears of joy
yeah how different the mentality was
right there with charles bronson is we
were [ __ ] cooking
cutting hair she's shot some [ __ ]
long time i was like the tv on music was
with the tv on donna
volume one and two greatest hits wow
that's where i learned to listen to that
album every time i went over they had
barbra streisand on or donna summer
there were italians that's hysterical
that's what i used to clean my house to
down the side of some of them live and
more they're my favorite albums it's
it's a lifestyle when they told me when
he told me the idea on the phone that
the family didn't do that i got sad in
my heart
because that's how i was introduced i
watched it on tv
now as well i would just sit there and
haul and listen to them say things to
each other nice shirt you wore today
john [ __ ] you [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up watch your language in
front of mommy don't talk don't be up an
[ __ ] in front of mommy don't cut you
know it was this thing that i didn't
have in my house yeah we talked at
dinner but not three [ __ ] kids you
know
that's a different part of society
that
you know i i [ __ ] yeah that was but i
i would envy you as a kid yeah i had the
air conditioner
the other day i'm sitting there going
when i came from cuba
i thought the more hot dogs i ate
the more american i was right please and
now they're telling me that kenny had
though
who's telling you
the [ __ ] is the government they're bad
for are they basically telling you i
gotta use turkey hot dogs like this
[ __ ]
over here
don't fall i call them
just
if you do that eat too much your eyes
will get slammed you never do that
mistake you cut on the bun you got like
a gluten-free bun gluten-free put it in
the [ __ ] tortilla do something
different yeah maybe a turkey yeah you
never cut back on the hot dog it's
always nathan or sad bread or one of
those other things there you go do they
even sell that out here all you ever see
is like a ballpark
yeah okay nathan's just around you cut
that [ __ ] down the middle with
some onions you fry that [ __ ]
with some yellow mustard
you need to do a recipe book like a
cookbook what the [ __ ] for like all your
random stuff if you have random dice was
talking about that that you talked to
his ex-wife you would always you guys
would just exchange recipes but really
it was you just telling her how to make
a dog you could
you could boil a hot dog and give it to
me with a bun this is a gummy hot dog oh
this is delicious get the [ __ ] out you
take a hot dog
boil that [ __ ] for a minute or
two you let those water start bubbling
you take the hot dog out and you throw
it in the frying pan right there slice
it down in the middle with some raw
onions and you throw some mustard right
in that [ __ ] in the pan right in
the hot mustard no
yellow yellow no no i'm saying but warm
mustard in there when you draw the cold
mustard back on
you throw the cold mustard back on okay
okay and it neutralizes everything
though you didn't finish eating him yeah
i'm sorry i'm talking how are you gonna
[ __ ] pick that new head dude and not
listen to the [ __ ] hot dog recipe
and you take like i was thinking i might
tell you like i'm looking for a business
like i like to own like a food business
but something simple so why don't you
something simple you know so me and my
wife wanna move to like louisville and
open up something like authentic like
[ __ ] so today i don't have a new hot
dog a [ __ ] hot dog
with a slice of american cheese raw
onions and baked beans like those bush
beans like in it god damn
god damn
after three bong hits of misery how how
is an a native american woman slash
irish and a cuban guy gonna open up uh
an authentic hot dog place the same way
i see [ __ ] hindus spinning around
pizzas in the air you ever go to my
mama's grand mama's pizza big mamas i
used to work for them
everybody in there has that armpit smell
oh that's disgusting they have when you
go to the one on sunset i know by
martell by rant ralph right
go in there at the door it smells like
that
like isis armpit like with somebody from
isis with their armpit would smell like
down in that desert for ten weeks
chopping off [ __ ] for everyone
listening he's talking about the pizza
place that delivered to the oscars this
year oh yes
it does smell in there well let me tell
you something about that pizza my friend
have you ever seen how they make pizza
by the slice yes it's a pre-cut piece of
dough
yeah don't tell me my pizza yes and they
sprinkle it on it but yeah so if that's
what the oscars eat welcome to my world
the rest of the world that's why i don't
eat pizza out here with these [ __ ]
gentiles i agree did you go on mama's
pizza they give you a clap of pizza and
you could see them make the slice you
don't do that you make the pizza as a
whole you let it colleguate then you
chop the [ __ ] up i'm not even a
dolly and i [ __ ] know that [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is wrong with people i don't
know the oscars that's why those mutts
are all gonna die a gluten-free and
[ __ ] uh plastic surgery you know
that's what they don't need [ __ ]
apples but meanwhile they have needles
and [ __ ] lasers in their eyeballs and
[ __ ]
botox
mama's papa on sunset i'm not trying to
be it is awful he's right as soon as you
close the door you smell armpit
you smell heavy duty i'm not going to
say what nationality i don't know i
don't want people saying you're being
[ __ ] racist or whatever
it just has that pungent desert odor to
it
but i can't tolerate i can't tolerate
that [ __ ] desert
so that's why i don't know mama's
somebody told me that pizza was good i
went in there one time and i ordered one
slice
just as a sample just to see when i saw
them put out the free fabricated slices
that's crazy i can't do it no i got
nervous this weekend because you asked
me for pizza place did he try it was it
okay it wasn't bad there's a place on
lowell canyon stone
cold stone let me tell you something
it's uh danielle's wood fire it wasn't
bad oh i know that well
pepperoni it wasn't bad i had the extra
cheese not bad but i had the salad
the cream italian dressing and the salad
[ __ ] delicious oh that's good i ate
that like at 10 o'clock at night i had
nothing else i just ate the salad with
this do you ever go to vetoes or joe's
veto's is on vetoes is on
yeah next to the chinese place yeah i'll
give you a dollar you can find parking
spot
that used to be my chinese place oh my
god i used to go rice
rice is the [ __ ]
rice
rice and i'm gonna tell you why rice is
just why not because of the chinese soup
or the twice cooked pork or anything
else
the chicken wings
oh they die do they have the sauce or
they're like the plain ones from like
sausages these cabbages yeah yeah this
is a fried chicken wing with pieces of
garlic and cream
and they give you four wings per order
and you dip it in the hot mustard you
sound like you may have an orgasm no no
no no this is something from another
[ __ ] dimension nobody was doing this
so then veto's open they have the pizza
place next door it's not bad but this
[ __ ] rice the wings that rice i've
been eating that rice says 1990
[ __ ] seven
and they changed owners now it's like a
sushi place or something right yeah they
did something i don't like you can't mix
flags yeah
i don't know you're gonna say japanese
you're selling thai why confused if you
put peanut in my twice cooked pork i
will stab every [ __ ] [ __ ] in this
[ __ ] restaurant i thought of you
again at oddball they had like stands
for food and one of them was chinese
food and someone next to me got it i
turned to paul i didn't look at it
behind me did someone just fart and she
pointed over it had the most disgusting
egg roll and um and red like they had
one of those but it looked like fake it
looked like a 7-eleven if they were
gonna do a chinese rib that's my
favorite restaurant i love 7-eleven [ __ ]
on that yeah the italian sandwiches
have you had that [ __ ]
but i am always inception
listen to it it's called the italian
sandwich listen to me going to 7-eleven
in the back i turned [ __ ] onto it he
did this to me like one in the morning
everyone breaks my balls i'm always in
seven and a half years forget the
chicken salad on wheat okay i should
kill you you'll be [ __ ] yeah the next
day
i got sick off once you go to 7-eleven
and you get the italian sub take it home
throw the lettuce out throw the
peppuccini because take the cold cuts
out toast the bread with the coat cuts
take it out
put lettuce
tomatoes pepperchinis and vinegar and
call me back tomorrow
and tell me who the [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with you just gotta dope
it up that's it he's gotta double up i
don't realize you've got to do it yeah
it's like taking a girl out of the
project delicious it's there you just
gotta dope it up you gotta put some
effort into it you just can't don't if
you take it homie you're gonna call me
go joey you disrespected me no you gotta
do it disrespect take it home take the
guts out all that arabian lettuce and
all that [ __ ]
and then the brown lettuce brown ones
brown yeah cause it's been there for
[ __ ] since tuesday then you take the
bread you toast it in one of those broil
ovens then you hit it with lettuce and
then you cut it so the bread is crunchy
yeah that shows yeah but who has time if
you're going to 7-eleven getting a sub
you don't have time for that yes you do
because you don't have to always act
like a [ __ ] savage all your [ __ ]
life you got to be civilized every once
in
awhile
see it's a whole complete situation a
lot of people don't plan this [ __ ] if
you're going to go to denny's if you're
going to go to [ __ ] 7-eleven and
support isis
oh get them big that's what you're
supporting is that that what
definitely a terrorist group look at
them the one by my house keeps changing
the color of his goatee
i got seven eleven cards you don't
change the color you go t
if you [ __ ] aren't in the paper if
somebody's not looking for you
why would you change the this from white
you know which one i'm talking about
yeah he was out there the other night
with the hose he always checked they're
always out there with the heart they're
always out there they're going to get
fined they're watching the gunpowder off
the [ __ ] front of them and they to
scare that homeless guy where he was
rapping to himself the white homeless
guy oh bro
how scary was that one dude that could
cross in the street wasn't it you and me
or steve simone mike and simone simone
yeah 7-eleven is where the action's
really it's like a nightclub i love it i
love it you can't some of them you can't
even get parking
yeah park across the street because they
got handicapped and they got that that's
that's my favorite how are you feeling
you ready for this i'm pretty high kill
this lesbian no good night i'd have to
for
one more piece here one more for the
government okay wow
what was that peer pressure for you i
know that work out he does he does when
we do live podcasts he does it on stage
so
but it seems like you have fun doing it
no but most of it's fun his eyes are
closed but he's enjoying himself i'll
watch espn for three days this is
exactly that anyway yeah i know but
actually before before i take it but i
want to talk to you it was before i take
a bite yeah
um it's a business you don't forget no
because that because i also love someone
to talk about but i picked up my
girlfriend she lives in englewood she's
mexican and we dropped we dropped the
mom off at uh at a mexican independence
day party right right across the street
and she called like right when we got
home like an hour later
five dudes in the alley that runs behind
their house drive by all got shot and
killed i don't know
and it was like she was yelling on the
phone she was yelling at the cops saying
it was their fault because they don't
come in late in the neighborhood
and it was just i couldn't and the mom
was scared and paul was kind of scared
but i couldn't imagine having to live
with that and it happens all the time
all the time and like when i like when
you were doing you never did stuff like
that but when you were like selling
drugs did you ever like worry about that
stuff or ever getting shot
i can't even imagine there's some
[ __ ] [ __ ] out there you see what's
going on now on the [ __ ] roads people
pull up to you and shoot you what about
last week some guy was just shooting
people at random all over what happens
all the time that happened on highland
yeah like this is this is crazy guys so
every step of this poor guy is joking at
that look at him swallow the [ __ ]
thing will you please hell yeah you
think one of the hookers out there
sucking the dick and then don't come
through the [ __ ] condom it tastes
like rubber [ __ ] milk
you think that she's making faces how
long is it going to take you to drink
this look at him holy [ __ ] jesus christ
what am i watching what am i dealing
with here
is this what jewish porn is what it was
a big beast it was a small tiny piece
now you're back look at you what do you
want to go eat at how many calories you
got left
i got 155 are you a weight watchers i'm
on everything i'm on my [ __ ] fit diet
whatever what's that the eagles one what
was the score 30 27 oh [ __ ] everybody
can they see them we're beating them for
a while yeah they were beating them 20
to six monday night you never pick a
book we never see a bookie with a
part-time job on a monday night no if i
tell you once i tell you a thousand
times don't [ __ ] with monday nights but
yeah do you like like there's drug
dealers who hang out by her house and i
always see them
like not even like dealing with gangs
because that's who did it apparently as
a gang but like when you were going to
pick just pick up some coke and
anywhere like and that's where it
happened i couldn't imagine having to
deal with that you never know when you
walk into a co council the cops are
gonna kick the door down
yeah i don't know when i saw you tonight
the main reason why i put you on the
show is
because this is something we talk about
all the time it's work and
come in when i met you you were the head
waitress at the comedy store
now you just taped a special for show
time six seven eight years [ __ ] later
seven and a half and i gotta take my
heart out to you i mean that's a great
accomplishment you know i've always
loved you and broke your balls
and we've had a lot of good laughs but
that's something that
you know and you're friends with dice he
loves you to death i mean you're his
goomba you keep him [ __ ] solid when
everybody when he's going off
you're the only one that could say shut
the [ __ ] up [ __ ] he's still married
yeah he's still married mexican chicken
he's still married to them she's mexican
italian and jewish
i don't [ __ ] believe yeah and he goes
you know joe every once in a while he'll
say joe diaz is right these latin girls
man these [ __ ] girls they're [ __ ]
nuts man well you're not even crazier
now i date her uncle
so you keep it on the family yeah he's
italian and jewish and how's max doing
max is doing great the band is
is together they're playing somewhere
the other door
is the name of a place they're playing
it's either on the 24th
september 24th or october 2nd now what's
max's brother dylan dylan yeah
they're called l.a rocks if you ever get
a chance look up their music it's
phenomenal how long have i known this is
still gosh yeah they just dylan will be
20 next week and max is 24.
crazy right i know max when he was
around 10.
i met
dylan when he he the mother was pregnant
with him
oh my god
how creepy is that
it's amazing
i've known andrew 21 years
you know i stopped going and i've been
going down there for 17. i know i know
andrew since he was his cousin used to
go in there right now jamie get the
[ __ ] cousin every night yeah
you know it's amazing every night i come
home the next morning you know i talk to
terry every night when i get home
you know if it's for 10 minutes some
nights i may get up yeah and go get
coffee with me outside i can't [ __ ]
believe you're like man i love that but
uh
you know
um
i tell how much the store has changed
it's a different beast now right and uh
what it is and what it's done to me the
last three weeks
it's just made me a different you know
and people don't understand like i made
this comment one night and i felt shitty
after i made it it was in front of like
two younger comics
and i said they said well we heard you
back at the store and i said you know
you can only get so good following
people at the haha and that flappers
you can generally get so good if you
want to be a killer you got to hang out
with [ __ ] killers
and that's the [ __ ] story
it makes your heart beat you know that's
what i want to be pushed you know it's
amazing when you work out by yourself
and when you work out with a trainer
yeah it's amazing when you go home and
go
well every muscle hurts everything hurts
because you push yourself because
somebody pushes you you know i would go
to the high tonight fresh off like i'm
gonna take a [ __ ] and go down to the ah
yeah i would look at a notebook
i would flap us a second it's true
when i go to the comedy store you better
look at your notebook before you go down
there oh yeah i'm gonna make a couple
notes you better you know you have to
it's it's and for me it was everything
yeah me too nobody understands
that i walked away from everything
because there was reasons i disrespected
the place
maryland it wasn't time you had to do it
time before right it was just everything
that was going on it was time to close
the door you have to know when to
[ __ ] close the door you have to know
when to fold them yeah and that's what
happened that's the maryland thing
i said i definitely got to stop going
down there you mean like the fight yeah
yeah yeah yes i got to stop going down
there it was well needed yes it was well
needed and i
i felt good you know i
and it's funny how it came to me you'll
watch the movie being there yeah but
peter said yeah
i had to do a colonoscopy and that week
they called me tommy got fired like on
wednesday
i don't i was on the east coast
something happened he got five and
somebody called and said you're gonna go
back to the store i said absolutely not
and i was getting a colonoscopy and the
reason why i have the colonoscopy is
because of marilyn martinez that's the
cancer she had yeah so i went home and
told my wife that they offered me a
colonoscopy she goes you know that's the
cancer that marilyn monroe if marilyn
would have done that she wouldn't have
died
marilyn also used to bust my balls about
being there
she still was like you've never seen
peter say i was in that [ __ ] movie
and i'm like no
why would i watch if he's not inspect
the clues though yeah she's like what's
the [ __ ] movie so it was on ifc one
night and i taped it with commercials
so this night like i watched it yeah
yeah because i was like oh my god being
there this is three months ago and i
taped and didn't watch it and i get up
one night you have to drink the potion
at five in the afternoon to make you
[ __ ] so you can put the camera for the
colonoscopy oh oh i was like wait what
the [ __ ] you gotta get up at two in the
morning
and drink another kool-aid yeah and that
makes you [ __ ] even more that goes deep
into the bowels oh wow wow yeah it's
probably aloe vera water or some [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] not sandpaper my
boyfriend does that and the next thing
is no no this is the [ __ ] that the
hospital gives you with a prescription
this is horrible
so i got up and they tell you don't go
back to sleep it's a waste of time just
sit so i smoke to joy and i watch this
movie
and it's basically about god
yes it's a mission of god
and when he walks away at the end
that's right
i cried a little bit like it really hit
me
and i said this is marilyn telling me to
go back to the store cut the [ __ ] i
don't know the next morning when i got
back in the cold i told you on the drive
down yeah i decided i'm calling for
spots at the store that's it amazing and
it was just like a sign it was that time
isn't it kind of crazy that like already
tweeted today that this was the day he
got past or whatever it's like still his
biggest accomplishment as he's filming a
tv show and like i was just thinking
it's kind of cool that
like sometimes you've talked as comics
about getting into different comedy
clubs you left the store for seven years
and you can just call them and like tell
me one of these spots and like they'll
just let you up like because you you got
passed no idea you're like a member of
it so like that must have been pretty
cool even though you left for seven
years
well he's still joe diaz he's still like
a relevant great comedy member you know
it tells me that there was a lot of
names on the wall yeah because there's a
lot of names of people who came through
town they don't even do comedy exactly
but there's names of people there who
really worked who really worked hard
and then they just zeroed out on the
comedy store i was one of those people
i knew when i came to town the first
place i was going to was the comedy
store i didn't know about the laugh
actually
i don't know about bud freeman's [ __ ]
improv
or hens mitchell and the [ __ ] hell
no he wasn't he wasn't even around at
that time in fact i worked with him in
promotions upstairs
me larry viziels and i got passed larry
vasil i was wrong with telemarketers
upstairs no you weren't i don't remember
that
for about three weeks or four weeks but
it's amazing that the comedy store meant
that to me like when i came to this town
i went to acapulco to eat dinner
and i went to the comedy store and i
seen james stevens the third
place i saw lenny eddie griffin
and i saw somebody else down there that
night wheels
okay
and they got me on stage before don
barris and that was like i could have
died that night even if there was eight
people in the crowd didn't matter yeah i
got on stage
the comedy story didn't matter no matter
whether it was an open mic nobody needs
to know that it was on my resume now
[ __ ] i went home that night i put
comedy star on that [ __ ] sunset
strip la [ __ ]
that was huge the o.r that's huge that's
and then for her to give telly to come
back after five minutes and then for her
to say that that you're a regular call
scott them off the spot you did you
showcase once twice wow one sunday three
minutes you made me come back and do ten
okay that was it
because i got here january 29th i was
past february 19th
wow three weeks in doug stanhope
preferred me
uh yeah that's your comic that we heard
you okay
and carlos didn't see oh okay and they
they were kind of her favorite
at least at that moment
she changed favorites a lot
i was just telling somebody the story
like
i worked i was her personal assistant
for like six years
the worst thing
but she got me my first stamp in my
passport so we went to the dominican
republic
to get stem cells
you know how [ __ ] frightening that
was that i had mitzi shore who every
comic is waiting for her approval and
she's in the [ __ ] dominican republic
getting stem cell injections
when you first started comedy did you do
it at the store because like i could i
worked at a place for too long sometimes
and like they always see you they always
saw me as like the intern
yeah so like did you was it weird was it
weird going there once i started doing
stand-up yeah like even getting
validation from joe dom irera
joe rogan any of these guys because you
guys i was idolizing you guys you know
not that i wanted to be a stand-up i had
no interest in being a stand-up but just
waiting tables and laughing my ass off
at you guys and i'm like when i started
i remember going to mitzi's and i was
like hey i'm gonna
start doing this one woman show
can i work it in the belly room and she
was like yeah because i would never go
on the original room stage unless
that's for real comics i'm gonna be an
[ __ ] in the belly room for a little
bit you know
and so she she was like yeah do it and
then dice came one night with his
girlfriend at the time
and watched and he was like you're doing
stand-up i'm like no this isn't stand-up
this is this is a one-woman show because
i'm talking about my family he's like no
and then he took me on the road with him
and that was it i was like oh [ __ ] i
haven't done the one woman show yet but
i have
like gone on with him and just like
filming this special is like a giant
thing it's only
10 minutes i think but i don't care
because it's dice giving me the
validation of you're a stand-up comic
that's hard dom watched me the other
night in the main room and said
you know dom had you on the show last
week with me a million times yeah but
i'm saying
he he sits and watches now and he goes
you know because i've worked with him in
philly i've worked with him in la jolla
i've you know all over but it just
you know that validation like him saying
really funny stuff like i'm picking out
bits and going this is terrific this bit
blah blah you know what i mean so i know
i'm doing it or going in the right
direction because you guys are good yeah
yeah yeah so it's like that's amazing
and to go on that or stage i would never
until i was ready i was terrified
to do it so i didn't go on for a long
time there but now it's my favorite you
know i get pissed if i don't have or
spots people have no idea that my first
okay so i got out of
prison in february and the guy that was
my roommate that i spoke to the other
day
uh said that you got to watch this
comedian and he kept giving me this va
saying what am i going to watch i'm in
the [ __ ] halfway house yeah yeah yeah
well i think it took him like september
it was andrew dice clay live from philly
oh yeah and i was blown away and that
new year's we weren't allowed to go out
in the halfway house
so i put that tape in i got a bunch of
guys
they said i okay and we had a party no
beers no drugs just soda and popcorn
and we dye the laughter and andrew nice
glad that's amazing and i think i got on
stage maybe two years later and to go to
the store and see him walking around oh
yeah because he would just be
yeah
it's mind-boggling for a guy and i would
never say a word to never
never
nothing
until one night there was a situation
with uh uh
mourinho and luca and he was furious he
said they were stealing his essence and
scott day and him were arguing and i
tried to explain to andrew that when you
start doing comedy you always do
somebody else until you get your persona
i go jesus when i started doing comedy i
was you till
my voice right
and he goes i never thought about it
that way
he was very angry but he called the
house three days later can you imagine
when you go home you check your message
and there's a message from andrew dice
clay what happened to you and they took
me on the road with the vacation yeah
with me bobby lee and jim norton before
jim norton yeah with uh
bad boys and family tour this is
craziness
and and it was you know what i'm saying
like that just gives you something
like if you die right there you're good
yeah like as you're going through heaven
you're like you know what whatever i
became a regular at the store and i went
on the road with andrew guy's glad what
did you do with your life
you know like that's how to me
it meant that it was a stripe like it
always has been i'll never forget andrew
for the shot of confidence he gave me
and everything he the first time the
first two or three movies i booked
was with andrew's advice
every time i use andrew's advice for how
he booked crime story
i do it i become andrew in a [ __ ]
room
he says that can't let them roll that
[ __ ] camera
roll that [ __ ] camera jack and
watch this
and he would do stuff backwards
like you would do the
everything like he would whatever you do
i want you to do it backwards
you know in an audition like he you know
it's just amazing the knowledge that man
has yeah the knowledge andrew dice clay
has
he could change your comedy stylings
with five sentences like do this hold
your hand this way
then he'll always throw something in
like mitzi that's outlandish
sometimes yeah yeah
when mitzi would see you on sundays
she'd always give you that one's a great
job
you're looking thinner i have an idea
and right there your whole body cringe
you're like next week i want you to
dress like fidel castro and put a
handcuff on
and go on stage i think it would be
funny she told me that 18. are you
kidding me but she would like this was
mitzi if mitzi told you something on
sunday she was going to forget it by
monday hopefully but if the talent
coordinator called you on wednesday and
re-mentioned it
you're that's not good yeah that's the
truth like what would you say like if
she saw you sunday we're going lee come
in lee
lee i want you to wear a rabbit suit
and put your [ __ ] on fire up on stage
at the end to close yeah you're like
that's funny mitch that's a great idea
and you leave
and hopefully she'll forget it
hopefully people will talk to her and
that's out of her memory but if the
talent coordinator calls you on
wednesday and goes highly i got a
message from mitty shaw she gave you a
spot at 10 30 in the main room she wants
you to wear the rabbi suit
oh my god you're [ __ ] done if you
don't wear that rabbi suit yeah and if
she caught you without it yeah you did
you were fired immediately she did that
i saw her do that to a number a handful
she told carnelie to put the guitar back
or something he didn't oh no she fired
him immediately yeah she [ __ ] she
he got she told him one night bring the
guitar back so when he got off stage he
kept saying [ __ ] up
i'm not i don't need no guitar i'm funny
as it is
so she told him again
if you don't do a guitar you're not
gonna get spots no more so he's out
there when they're yelling at the
building one night [ __ ] the comedy store
i don't need the comedy store i'll go to
the ice house and develop and i'll come
back here and i'll blow all these comics
out of the water
about two months later i see him at the
union
when they should do the you know
what was next to the [ __ ] union what
was the place where dane cook got made
at sunset uh upstairs uh
yeah yeah yeah yeah dublin dublin
upstairs dublin had an upstairs yeah
well they did comedy but yeah
yeah
there was a room up there one night we
were all up there on wednesday night we
did some comedy up there ahmed and jay
i'm mad and jay we all this was way
before it became that it was there's
once a month this is the summer of 98
summer of 99. danny kelly was the talent
coordinator oh i forgot he's in there
for a minute 98 throughout 98 throwing
heat
throwing heat
and i john carnelli's then he's like
yeah i'm thinking of going back to the
war started between him and i because he
says i'm thinking i'm going back to the
stoner
and i go what happened to mr i'm not
ever playing the guitar again yeah i go
i thought you were going to develop
somewhere else mister i'm not going to
play the guitar i go now you're begging
for a spot i guarantee you show up with
a 12-man band
he [ __ ] was pissed so
do you guys have a thing
not anymore he's disappeared who knows
what he does i i've worked with him like
two months john carnell which one are
you talking about uh in vegas at the lab
factory
the the weird one the one they used to
hang out with with johnny
johnny okay so
i see him about a week later and he has
a little bit of attitude towards me
and he goes to me oh you're getting
ready to go on stage shouldn't you be
doing a line of code
isn't that what makes me no way when i
go [ __ ] listen i don't need no [ __ ]
guitar i don't need a line of coke and
he's kept talking he was at johnny
sanchez and i had a heineken bottle oh i
had a glass they hate each other now
yeah yeah they all do everybody hates
johnny carnelli i take the [ __ ] glass
and i whip it at his head from like
where the lineup is
and the o.r he was by like midway he
ducked but they got the [ __ ] out of that
like that was it once somebody throws a
glass yeah comedy store like i'm crazy
doug what's up glass at somebody yeah
good yeah so the next night i'm driving
by martel and i see him and i'm parked
i'm in traffic by what's the bar that
closed down
i crossed from 7-eleven why
but terry used to hang out everybody
used to go there at night oh yeah
coaching horses horse it's now something
i saw sanchez walking out of there and i
beat him he goes pull over he goes last
night i had nothing to do with me it was
all john carnelly because i threw a
[ __ ] glass you know
i love johnny sanchez throws him right
under the bus oh good yeah let that out
i had that fun it was at a taco a little
tony's better here for you [ __ ]
it's monday september 15th
get out there [ __ ]
what
how you feeling at least i'm really
happy when somebody breaks your heart i
would have been hyped before that who
took who takes care like uncle joey play
the music
that's why it says
you're taking a testing break come on
let's go music music
i mean
all right what what happened [ __ ]
what's the gig on the valley everybody's
giggling i love tony bennett i'm just
very proud of you
thank you and we're you know we're doing
um an australian tour for the first time
who is me and dice come on october 1st
through the 29th and uh will be
all over australia a bunch of i think
it's like 18 shows 17 shows something
like that and then 29 days yeah and one
show in uh new zealand
you'll have a good time man i can't wait
neither one of us have ever been and who
else is going just you two uh his wife
uh happy face
it was like a road manager slash
karate school in jersey yes yes happy's
the band
uh and then who
one other guy might go i don't know like
a manager or something uh
something like that his manager bruce i
think i think he's going i don't know
every day it changes so we'll see and
you still get on stage every night every
night i get on stage um
where even if it's like a stinky one i
still do that i don't care like bar like
some guy came up to me at the improv
last night he's like hey you ever do a
bar show i'm like hell yeah i don't care
about not getting paid because you don't
make your money you make your money on
the road you know but to come up with
new stuff you got to do those shows and
to still feel like alive you got to do
those shows i mean i don't adam's great
to me at the comedy store so i get like
late night or like a killer opening like
i opened the main room and then i did
like an 11 45 so it's kind of like you
get the best of both worlds and
i did a 145 the other night in the belly
room after the long beach and opening
the main room i love that bouncing
around trying to get three four shows in
a night you can get you can get three
four is
tough done it
last week
three i could do three hours
it's just driving at night yeah i could
do three in the night yeah it's just the
driving part is [ __ ] tough
before you could do it like if you have
the lap factory on the monday and the
economy still open mike you got those
two covered so you're gonna pop two more
so you catch the the haha mm-hmm i
haven't been there in a while you catch
the ha ha contest tonight
and you catch flappers
oh flappers yeah there's always a open
mic there i forgot about that she'd go
to laugh actually didn't jump up here
and do those two
and then go to the comments that was up
until two what about the uh you could do
could you do the improv too could you
like like five or six so yeah well he's
just monday triple crowns on monday i
got like three triple crowns it needs to
be freaky monday so white people go from
eight o'clock to 8 40. when do you go up
oh you're white
this is when they did that i don't do it
no more
they don't do it no more that's freaky
monday i feel like i remember that
yeah it was david pablo francisco and
duck staff oh yeah yeah and chris uh the
guy from friday it was a great show on
monday night yeah now it's hosted by
somebody else great gift from chicago
hold on that does all the movies yeah
with the blue eyes mike
whatever but they only put three comics
on and they're all black yeah yeah you
know unless you want to submit yourself
to that [ __ ] torture on monday night
it's back i do do a lot of black sheep
yeah everybody's on the phone yeah you
know what with the black phones with the
black for black phones with the black
rooms i always tell people we last a
minute
have you ever done um the sam manuel on
a wednesday for the laugh factory i just
did that last week my boyfriend was
screaming laughing i saw him pacing in
the back because he saw me sweating what
is it is it just it's mixed it's it is a
two-hour drive it's predominantly black
but it is mixed but it's like real
the worst of every mix does that make
sense like the worst yelling out yeah
the worst yelling they would yell at me
gabriel get off the stage yeah they make
dice shows look yeah
no no no i
i used to drive to china for 40 bucks
on sunday night this is good money
though because it's the laptop
yeah
please man i used to drive to [ __ ]
san bernardino
for [ __ ] [ __ ] money and all these
things i developed in the latino rooms i
was very lucky because there was 30
mexican rooms i'm very fortunate because
i always got 11 45 at the spot that
spot's always going to be there so now i
got his choice i could sit at home and
do nothing or go make 80 bucks for some
blow i would hate wow i would hit castle
latina and pick up 40 and hit felipe's
room and pick up 40. there you go
should we be right there pick up a 50.
boom you got 30 left over four games
yeah just give it away
what does it give you anxiety because
like i've gone out like a few times in
the last few weeks with you and like
you'll say i got 10 50 you'll get there
at 10 45 and they're 30 minutes behind
yeah like it would give me anxiety
knowing actually i was supposed to be at
the store yeah and and you didn't even
have a cell phone so you could probably
couldn't call and be like hey all right
is it cool if i'm late like does that
happen a lot where are you
at the store i always know they're gonna
be late behind me or i'm gonna walk off
and they're gonna go thank god you came
we have no comics yeah
okay
you always have a 20-minute window at
the store okay
so that as long as that you know when i
was coming up you always had dice mooney
or eddie griffin on stage where they
were bumped three nights a week yeah so
you always knew that so if you called at
nine
and they said griffin's here
i'm just gonna take my time with
philippe basically don't even bother
yeah don't even bother till about one
you just know you just know how to time
them so look what would happen let's say
you had a spot didn't call in and just
missed it like
do you give do you not get brought back
like a comedy store if you have a spot
and you miss it nothing nothing just
call i called the next day and
apologized you fell asleep you know
whatever it is you were tired you got
caught in traffic whatever you know you
just there's a lot of clubs that won't
[ __ ] tolerate the laugh factory won't
tolerate it yeah i've had a cancel at
the store like for like if filming runs
too long or something you know and
that's
they don't get pissed yeah they don't
get pissed and the lab factory
i guess i haven't canceled on them yet
i go if they bump me i leave and then
they get pissed off from me they won't
give me a spot for a month
i've already been bumped a thousand
times i'm not doing it and every time i
go live actually danger goes to bumming
because they put me on last so he
doesn't wanna last so he bumps me i
leave i don't give a [ __ ] they don't do
that at the store no more nobody comes
in to bump anybody like that and if they
do they do 15 minutes i don't mind judd
appletoe's been coming in yeah and he'll
do 15. yeah and they get off not doing
an hour two hours
listen man my uh
it was a long time without the store i
really appreciate it again i got the
appreciation i got when i remember being
out there one night at one o'clock in
the morning and waiting
like in those days that was the last no
no no
if there was spots till two
yeah you would give me one in the
morning
and i'm sitting out there when i talking
to dave tyree
and going here i am at one in the
morning he goes i guarantee if they put
that sign up
spots at the comedy store one in the
morning they'd still get a hundred
signatures how lucky are you you know
how lucky you am oh yeah that's how i
look i'm very fortunate man that's right
i'm very you know when i went into the
laugh actually they told me he told me
to leave buddy you don't belong in this
town you belong in a night club
you're the night club comedian you're
dirty people love you in las vegas but
in las vegas
i didn't do it i didn't listen to him no
the improv made me a regular but the
comedy store
she loved exactly what the [ __ ] we were
doing
exactly
all different like you can never look at
the lineup and go oh all these people
are the same they're all you might go in
there and brian shell might be up there
doing impersonations of elvis or
remember that
the main room she'd have that janice
heart
swinging [ __ ] around her neck what was
the fact check what was the italian
chick from boston oh cheryl vendetta
where is she uh she said she just got
married to a woman
and uh she's doing great she just bought
a house in studio city shelvin daddy's
still around she's doing comedy i think
so
i think she does a cooking show
comedy cooking show something like that
together
i know feverman does it too but i think
cheryl does i don't know i have to look
that up i could have messed that up it's
just amazing the people there but she
was a great girl yeah
i went to there with a lot of great
people a lot of shitty people to go up
there i just told already on the phone
like i don't know how you feel
i think i'm gonna get them on the show
next week i think right now i got the
best working comic is sebastian
maniscalco wow interesting i think uh
he's made me [ __ ] pee the last three
weeks and then it's hard to make me
laugh at this point in the [ __ ] game
i agree
he's made me [ __ ] laugh he's so
overly animated i love it i can't i like
that kind of [ __ ] andrew meets gang cook
yes andrew meets danko but he definitely
found himself he found himself
and that's what makes him funny yeah
that's what makes him very funny is that
he found himself that material is for
him he knows that the [ __ ] thing
about the chipotle
the meat and the cheese
the bouncing the bouncing i [ __ ] died
you know little things like my niece is
12. she loves him
because they could watch it and he don't
curse he does encourage he he bounces
around he's silly you know that's weird
i never realized he was clean yeah ish
he can be dirty dirty but he won't okay
he prefers if they pay him big money
he'll be cleaning and then go bad dad
that's crazy because some comics when
they're cleaning you like really happy
you notice it
i never noticed with him he's the second
guy i'm impressed with the most
who's the first you oh i love that you
know what that bro when i met sebastian
he was like vito and when they brought
vito over he was half [ __ ] remember
he wouldn't he kept singing that song on
with no shirt on the [ __ ] horse
he was [ __ ] at first later on he
blasted somebody sucked his dick and he
got crazy
but when they first brought him who knew
i didn't know the backstage when he had
the [ __ ] measles and they put him in
the room by himself and he was singing
out the window
then he got his dick sucked
lumps away what does he do he just he
just creeps away the [ __ ] and we
wonder why we're not higher in the
itunes charts
right out of them all suck my dick i
tunes the autism i don't give a [ __ ] let
me give a shout out to some beautiful
people here
daryl marriott
william mcgrath i love your clock sucker
michelle el nino michael el nino who the
[ __ ] knows
adam rose
peter kendrick james middlewich
lando rayden podcast brandon oh and
jared chorizo i don't know
i want to give you a shout out that's it
that's all that's going on that's very
nice who are these people nice people
that you know they listen to the podcast
they subscribe they always make a nice
comment which i try to make that day by
telling them how to acknowledge them you
know i love that yeah
you listen thank you for [ __ ]
supporting us we use this type of
language you talk about isis armpits not
everybody likes this you know what i'm
saying people listen to lawrence what
would never turn this show on yeah no
i'm here in this [ __ ] room
they killed my mother they killed my
father they killed my brother and they
sent me on a [ __ ] boat and [ __ ]
he got the autism sucked out of them
yeah that's amazing what do you have to
do to get the isis arm put out i don't
you have to tap
no that's a good
i don't know if there's like a sexual
thing bro i don't even think isis exists
what i think it's real i was looking at
the tape playing the ymca i was on the
epileptical and i'm watching this thing
if you're gonna chop my head off i'm
gonna run
you're gonna catch me they just sit
there like [ __ ] dummies like all
right chop my head off and they got an
orange robe on you know it would take
nine of those [ __ ] stinky [ __ ]
couldn't agree with that
and after you made me kneel down if i
know you're coming with a hot knife you
don't have to catch me and cut my
[ __ ] head off don't you think they
drug them or something
don't move yeah
they're just sitting there like [ __ ]
like one of jerry's kids they don't know
what the [ __ ] going on they're just
sitting there like in a [ __ ] chat
we just dropped down again on the itunes
gives a [ __ ]
i just love i don't give a [ __ ]
what's in your heart i would like wolf
blizzard to be like and now we have
special correspondent joey diaz [ __ ]
in iraq
and you're like
those [ __ ] [ __ ] aren't real
[ __ ] the isis [ __ ] iraq i don't have
what am i gonna do
i'm only one i agree
with everybody but you you're right it
would take a lot more
they would have to draw they definitely
drove them because they did
this [ __ ] show up with this
black mask and i'm doing something
unless they tie my feet what are you
gonna do typo i'll [ __ ] run for it
and give him an
you could stab me 18 times i'm fat i
don't give a [ __ ] but i don't believe
they just sit there that's why i think
those tapes bro
you know what i'm not a conspiracy
theorist we never saw obama middle eye
and we don't know he did anything fishy
we don't know nothing we know they show
us
we know they show us films look at this
[ __ ] flight went down nobody said no
now we realize the russians shot it down
really and people still are saying none
that flight that was missing also
that was the russians who shot that dog
did you see that another one of their
planes went down malaysian airlines yeah
that's the kiss of death russia's only
just shooting them at will it's like a
[ __ ] tv game for them what's up these
white kids they buy those games they sit
there grand
look at me i'm stealing a car russia
said [ __ ] it let's just shoot down a
bunch of malaysians well they got 2 000
of them left how many people in london
malaysia go look at their population
what they got 10 [ __ ] malaysians one
was i'll give you a dollar tell me the
last time you met a [ __ ] malaysia
a dollar i'll give you when was the last
time you met a [ __ ] malaysian i
really don't know
they every time they leave the russians
shoot them no they plan to leave it then
get the [ __ ] machine ready 29 million
i don't know about one [ __ ]
malaysians and they keep getting the
[ __ ] planes
i don't know one malaysian i don't know
one [ __ ] malaysia i was trying to
think of it but then i figured i was
polynesian from like the chinese
restaurants but
i know i figured that out how many
people are in polynesia i don't know
let's find out are you googling this yes
wow
we don't [ __ ] around i know this is just
great producers well he gets right to it
he really doesn't [ __ ] around i'm sorry
you know these malaysian people i don't
know these people i don't know
i don't know these people two million
for polynesia
oh that went down that dropped a lot
they used to be a polynesian restaurant
the maikai delicious
spare ribs
that's what my friend used to call the
bartending little karate chop for five
bucks
what for five bucks roger holloway the
irishman he would be talking to him mid
conversation the bartender will walk
home and go charlie the guy would bend
over and go hot
a little bit more the polynesian was
named charlie that guy's name was nice
and at the mine after chance dragging in
he was a chinese chinese guy and his
name was harry
oh they always have they were trying to
white wash them they're always watching
yeah yeah yeah they always have harry
jackie
i don't eat their food
none of it the entire orient no sushi
nothing
i don't trust them dog i love children
and i'm going to lose a lot of weight
what are you doing i'll show you
kangaroo meat
don't they have good chinese food in
philly
i don't know i wouldn't go there you
don't need chances when don't you eat
chinese since i'm born since why is this
i don't know maybe my dad was in korea
or something i don't know i don't eat
that [ __ ] so your whole family chinese
food some of them do but we don't it's
not like a thing
we never had like chinese night
i know what a shame
what a [ __ ] irish we like bland food
you know we like you would break steve
simone's heart right now
yeah i know i love that bit with the
thing but he grew up in the suburbs they
know where to go i mean we have a
chinatown in philly in the center city
i went there before i didn't eat nothing
you need to spare it or not
what was the last time you ate pork
fried rice never i don't eat rice
at all steamed rice no
since when since i'm never i've never
my brother billy told me they were that
that that the rice were maggots
what about mexico he said they turned
into that in your stomach nope never had
it
oh my god i never even had well i used
to eat hot dogs until we were like me
billy and bobby my brothers were
fighting over there was two
and then we
you know flipped for it and me and bobby
won and billy didn't and billy's like a
terrorist
so he watched me boil these things and i
was i don't know eight nine and i was
boiling it my mom was sleeping because
she had ten kids and she was raising us
by herself so she was out like a [ __ ]
life and we were just up at like it was
like three in the morning i was making
them and as i was about to eat it billy
my brother billy was like be careful you
don't bite a vein
and i was like what
he goes you know that's like a cow's
dick
and i was like are you kidding and that
was it me and bobby threw up and he ate
both of our hot dogs
and i never had one since since that day
you really are [ __ ] if i knew this i
wouldn't have you in the park no i'm
really [ __ ] [ __ ] so what do you
eat i plain very plain cheese chicken
yes okay i eat steak i meat yeah i like
a burger cheeseburger take good care of
yourself you don't need to i don't know
it's rice is like a really empty calorie
it's not about i eat pasta tons of pasta
it's not about because
i like sweets like i i rode my bike
to
santa monica to get a pumpkin pie
doughnut at dunkin donuts i don't [ __ ]
around you know what i mean i'll do that
i also ate an entire ice cream cake the
other night i have problems what kind of
ice cream
the basket around my my
dice's wife had that for uh uh her mom's
party and and max they both just had
birthdays and it was that praline right
now she started [ __ ] around uh-uh
carvel cake is
to die for from ralph's right here and
sherman oaks yeah all of them gone yeah
but then you can get the little ones
ate it all by myself you still have half
no because it wouldn't have gone that
was so [ __ ] good so good
we tore that [ __ ] up carville i grew up
on this did mercy
when's her birthday january 8th
oh okay
so we made it last yeah it's like uh
rana's easy son yeah so we made it last
uh last year we said it for her birthday
and what they're going to do on a
birthday party she had to track
in the middle of the track you can have
a party like
yeah so get a carvel cake get some
pastrami
get some [ __ ] cuban food some pork
some black beans and rice and throw it
down i'll eat the cake
yeah
it's gonna be during the week at
birthdays are on thursday or something
i'm at the melrose improv that saturday
night so we haven't decided for a
two-year birthday i don't know where the
[ __ ] can throw the party at that's great
too
[ __ ] people with kids you know
lauren has you remember lauren peltz my
best friend she has two kids uh
she'll be three huh no no no she left
she left because her she got pregnant
and um
they have two kids now and her her son
is uh named jedi
and people make fun of her but i love it
i think it's cool jedi xavier fishman so
cute and that is it's like a star track
wars which one is it
who's jedi a star wars thing thank you
it's a star wars she wasn't work where
is she working no more she helps with
her husband he's a producer he puts tv
shows on the internet
and he has a huge company and has a ton
of shows and stuff that he does work
with lebron james they have a bunch a
bunch of shows that were nominated for
webleys like that's the webisode thing
yeah yeah so danny has a huge company
and um lauren helps with him but for the
most part
she's got two kids you know she's got
under one and a two and a half year old
[ __ ] ages dog yeah what's up lee look
at the shape i was thinking i was
thinking you were going to have mercy go
up go beat up jedi xavier why
because he got a license he hates that
name i i can just tell tell me the truth
do you hate it or you like it what's the
name jenny i don't give a [ __ ] don't
listen to it yeah jedi xavier
danger
fishman
danger's his middle name
is [ __ ] danger right there let's have
a play date then let's make them fight
each other [ __ ] it come on you know what
he's a big kid plus it's peltz's kids
she you don't get offended i don't want
my daughter in that world yet and she's
still i was thinking about tonight i was
looking at her drawing you know
and i think about my mom like my mom was
a great mom and a lot of avenues but one
thing my mom took from me was that
innocence
from like seven or ten
like i wasn't that innocent anymore like
i was already doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] sure
that kid that age didn't do
and she didn't give a [ __ ] and that's
why i don't giggle
i'm not a giggling type of guy i don't
react to that [ __ ] you know
they just and i don't want to take that
from mercy all that fighting and all
that that's [ __ ] yeah but it was a
different time it wasn't difficult
because i have a nephew that's just
turned 14 and my mother says 14 there's
no way that kid's 14. you know i mean we
just grew up in a different time now you
can do that keep their innocence you can
coddle them a little more i mean they're
kind of [ __ ] now but you know this
person
not that you want a colleague but you
don't want them to save that yeah i lost
that at seven
easily not that not that i was i was a
light i lost my life's virginity
not my sense of virginity i lost my life
virginia i had a younger race usually
people lose that 15 60 yeah their life
rigidity
where they see a little bit more than
the rest of the kids i lost an eight
and eight i already had [ __ ] in my head
that i shouldn't have been i was smoking
at nine yeah full-blown smoking
we just were we were robbing out of the
supermarket we would have competitions
who could steal the most i mean like we
were like [ __ ] now where's your dad
my parents split up how old were you uh
eight or nine it was like right in
between mary yes
he only moved like five blocks away he
was right there he just didn't really
give a [ __ ] hey yeah all right
yeah we are we are tight like i make fun
of him a lot but
i did have to work for him every day
from fourth grade all the way to 12th
grade in the typewriter store because my
mom had to go get a real job because
typewriters weren't paying the bills and
he wasn't paying child support and there
was 10 kids
so the older half just started working
after school and then we were like oh
what do we do
you know so we got in trouble a lot but
then
he would make us come to the typewriter
store and we would like have to sweep up
or
answer the phone and things like that
like we had jobs
we had jobs to do not chores middle
class lower middle class i would go even
lower and that's uh that's like a class
that's been taken out of this country
pretty much yeah i don't know we would
be poverty stricken
now i guess it's amazing how much things
have changed how hard it is for a family
of four
yeah two children and a parent and a
wife how hard it is can't go to laker
games dodger games are out of your
future
unless you get better i never did that
and people are like how come you don't
go to games because we can afford that
and my mom worked for the phillies and
the eagles that was her second job how
did christmas even work it was insane it
wasn't i don't know how she did it i
really really don't i like
because she would make it like it was
the best people would come to our house
and be like this is the best everything
and we didn't really have much sometimes
she would buy [ __ ] from a fire sale but
we would turn it into because we were a
little creative like you know change it
up a little bit and then wow this is the
best game ever
and she was like i didn't even think it
worked like that which it probably
didn't but that's what we did
so we would just like turn things around
we had the best time all my brothers and
my older brothers and sisters are so
creative that's a sin like they love to
make costumes and [ __ ] like that like my
sister karen makes amazing costumes and
she designs all of the costumes for my
nieces that uh because they do she's a
dancer
and so she makes all her costumes and
always has
like her whole life she's amazing with
that and then
they would win every halloween costume
they would go up center city or go up
south street and win like five thousand
dollars ten thousand on all these prizes
because they were good like that they
just turn it into something
it's really amazing when you grow up uh
not having a lot of things yeah
you figure out how to make something out
of nothing nothing yeah you figure out
and
i was very fortunate growing up my mom
always had money till my mom died and
then i was thrown into the avenue where
you grew up yeah i got to see it
i got to see three kids in the house and
how they acted wow what i thought was
life well i thought it was just three
kids liking each other yeah don't know
why you have my [ __ ] socks on i
didn't know the way you [ __ ] say you
know yeah yeah when you're pulling a
knife out of one brother's hand so he
don't stick it in the other brother's
eye
it's a [ __ ] problem but that's what
we did that's it
you you would make yourself crazy like
that it's really amazing that you
when you talk to people you could tell
who grew up
wanting and who grew up you know looking
down like yeah
you could tell in a way like when i talk
about a child a rough childhood i'm not
talking about you getting [ __ ] in the
ass by the priest i'm talking about a
rough childhood when you come home at
five and there's nobody home because
they're both working yeah that's a rough
childhood when you come everybody's
working make your own [ __ ] sandwich
till seven and fend for yourself till
seven and we love it as kids but think
about it we all rather come home
and have your mom waiting for you with
an apron on with you you imagine and my
mom would have loved that yeah my mom my
mom would have loved that your mom
didn't work uh for a little bit but then
for most my childhood no
and then when you got home at three she
was there yeah my dad my dad worked
nights so he was there a lot too
oh wow cookies ready to rub your feet my
mom was my dad we're downstairs but uh
i don't i almost don't want to even
bring it up but we're talking about kids
like what do you think about like that
adrian peterson [ __ ] that's good well
like i mean honestly if you're hitting
we got our asses kicked dude my father i
don't get it i don't understand with
belts buckles i mean [ __ ]
cars my dad would hit my dad was [ __ ]
marine he was crazy like this is
hilarious we just didn't have the
capability of an iphone to rat them out
and say hey
this fucker's hitting me you can't do
that that's what they did the kid ratted
him out other than a couple spankings i
was very lucky i never really got my mom
used to hit us with a wooden spoon
remember that so what you telling me
isn't for a society you cannot hate your
child
if you lay a hand on your child the cops
are going to come yes if you grab your
child and go you cannot [ __ ] stick
your fight yeah you cannot stick your
[ __ ] fork
in the electrical outlet you're
like the way i heard it described in the
news was like the law is
it's basically like based on what the
community thinks so there's no like set
law like you can't you can't do the
stake we can do the belt or just the
hands it's like based on whatever that
jury thinks is over the line i do think
he took it a little too far i mean the
thing is is like when you're getting hit
and i believe my dad took it too far but
we weren't gonna say anything he's a big
[ __ ] guy he's got a lot of weapons
we didn't say anything but there was
times where like my brother jimmy
couldn't go in to christmas dinner at my
aunt's house because my dad beat him up
so bad and he was
you know i mean literally like he was a
street fighter
so you know it's i don't agree with what
the man did no but i'm saying
you know i think
it's just
everybody does it i just don't know that
everybody gets caught if he wasn't a
political figure would anybody even care
or know about it no
it happens all the time
it sucks the wife the ray rice thing
i was talking to my mom about that and i
was like what did you think you know you
see the video and she's like you know
she go i go she hit him like 30 times
not that i agree that he should hit her
back but still she did hit him a lot
and my dad taught me never hit anybody
unless you expect to get hit back
no matter who or what it is if it's a
dog if it's a man if it's a whatever
you're going to get hit back so i was
like all right i believe what my dad
said i was talking to my mom and she
told me that a long time ago she was
pregnant with one of the older brothers
and sisters and she got mad at him and
she was hitting him
and i go you hit him my dad's a big guy
and i go you hit him what did he do she
goes he didn't do anything he was seeing
she goes he literally was foaming at the
mouth and he was like if you hit me one
more time i'm gonna hit you and she goes
go ahead i dare you and i go damn you
got
this guy's crazy like he joined the
marine so he can kill people and not
have to go to jail for it like he's a
little off you know what i mean and
she's like pushing his buttons
i thought it was great women do
exactly but i said i i almost called my
dad and said hey man thanks for not
hitting her back [ __ ] well you you know
i want to stab terry every other [ __ ]
day too you know [ __ ] but that's what
love
no but she might as well hit me when she
don't turn the light off
you guys don't [ __ ] hit me when
i tell you ten times turn that [ __ ]
light off in the hallway i can't wait
you know
that's why you [ __ ]
it's funny because that's like a simple
thing and then i have friends that fight
over a car seat being moved up and back
oh no okay
so it's like do women just not retain it
or do they just not think about it
because it's always the girl who doesn't
do the thing i don't know what the
[ __ ] on her mind
i don't [ __ ] a kid i don't ask she's
chasing the baby around before the
[ __ ] oh okay
sorry terry i tried to [ __ ] take [ __ ]
out turn the [ __ ] light off from the
balcony we need we need to call in and
like repeating i grew up in the house
and they tell you you say it in that
time
i grew up in a society where people tell
you one time like to me for their own
part
that's right yeah and that's it you
don't park there it's not why why not
it's a free country yeah all right then
park there
your car is on fire
well i didn't mean to i told you not to
park there yep who the [ __ ] are you
gonna question anything just park next
to it [ __ ] around the corner don't give
a [ __ ] away you park we just told you
don't [ __ ] park that don't worry
about who or why it's a great country
there's no free there's no [ __ ] in
this neighborhood yeah this is [ __ ]
they were free ain't no [ __ ] [ __ ]
my brother jimmy's wife she leaves all
the house lights on i don't know why
like she'll go in every room and it's
just a little row home you know it's not
a big elaborate but it's every and he
goes hey
madison avenue yeah what the [ __ ] that
light shut the [ __ ] up
my wife will tell you a story at the
park
for 10 minutes and not look at mercy
mercy's over there running she's telling
you so jen terry i don't give a 10 [ __ ]
about jet that's what i give a [ __ ]
about look at that right there don't
take your [ __ ] eyes off her all right
and she'll look at me like i'm crazy
don't take your [ __ ] eyes off
no story that you have to tell me is as
interesting as that little thing running
over there and if you do want to tell me
a story tell me the story just look that
way right look that way you can tell me
whatever [ __ ] story you want 20 times
i don't give a [ __ ] i'll listen i'll
jump up and down
but look that way don't look at me
and every time she'll tell me he's
trying to go terry look that way
that's the thing it's funny [ __ ]
drives me crazy you got to watch these
kids dogs definitely
you know i'm all [ __ ] school man dogs
come out of nowhere that's funny you say
that's exactly how i feel i'm not
terrified of that i'm i'm petrified for
her because it [ __ ] my world up for
five or six years when i started getting
bit by dogs
you create this fear and then you're
scared of animals yeah and if i wasn't
intelligent enough to overcome it on my
own when i was like seven it would have
followed me that i was like 30 because
you're not you have this fear of a
certain [ __ ] thing
so i i put it together when i was like
eight or nine that the more i tightened
up around them they were going to fight
fear when i loosen up they won't bite me
so do you know how hard it is at a young
age to have fear but to keep it cool
most people can't
you can't do it after you're 16 17. but
i had to put it together as long as i
keep getting [ __ ] bit you know what
i'm saying
keep your eyes on the [ __ ] kid terry
terry i don't give a [ __ ] about
tennessee or
he's playing the guitar for let's happen
to do with me though
they really don't look straight the
[ __ ] head don't take your eyes off
the [ __ ] she's in my prayers
she's in my [ __ ] prison
tennessee yeah they tell you all these
you know where she's from no yeah yeah
they want to tell you like all these
rules i don't give a [ __ ]
let me tell you something i told you ten
years ago i'm gonna tell you again i
don't give a [ __ ]
if my weed ain't on fire and my sneakers
are fine
i don't give a [ __ ] my sneakers are fine
i can't wait to get a conversation with
mercy like like three or four one like
you can actually go back and forth i
can't wait that's gonna be an emmy
award-winning show oh please that's mine
that's my little irish woman bro i'm
trying to raise her to be a killer may
my uh boyfriend fight overseas
how many months you've been with a
little over a year really look at
eleanor's uncle ronnie
but he his we fight over because he says
uh
tennis shoes
[ __ ] tennis shoes sneakers snakers
he grew up in atwater he's a hood rat
poor thing by the way
that [ __ ] you broke his heart he's
never been the same which one uh
ricky oh my god hey schmidt i didn't
break his heart
he broke his own heart that [ __ ] momo
on twitter he talked so much [ __ ] man
i had a bantam or whatever it's called
flop block from
facebook yeah because he was writing
nasty [ __ ] about kids yeah hey man you
can write whatever the [ __ ] you want
about dice or wheels say it to their
face let them [ __ ] fight you they're
old enough but don't talk about the kids
man
their kids didn't do [ __ ] to you
they can't
they're not responsible for whatever
fight you had with him 20 [ __ ] years
ago i think about three weeks ago i
decided that there's a mental health
issue there no he's [ __ ] crazy
the twitter guy this kid yeah he was the
impression
and he was he was here he was here a
month ago i know i was out i was in la
jolla thank god
yeah cause i would have beat him
that they were gonna they didn't give
him a spot but his name was on the wall
you see that that you said that earlier
just because you got passed you gotta
stay relevant man you can't just get
past and think it's over you made it no
you gotta work hard
hard and you can't just tag out and go
for six years and you know
come back after eight years i'm gonna be
nice but i'll skip a lot but i'm saying
like come back and just think oh
everybody the c should park because you
were funny
eight years ago on stage no [ __ ] that i
don't know who they were he said he even
told me himself because he didn't call
me because he knew i would say why are
you here yeah because i would never you
know it's a constant
i love him i love that kid but it's a
constant if you have a it's a cigarette
it's a lighter
if you have a rolling paper do you have
a toothpaste what do you have a
toothbrush i don't know you know if you
pick them up
if you pick them up you're stuck with
them because the house he was supposed
to stay at when you get there at two in
the morning they're not gonna be there
yeah they're gonna leave the key
now you're stuck with them and it's a
whole weekend and do you really want to
go with somebody well oh i lost my
wallet on the plane now you get
cigarettes money
it's non-stop and he would call me and
say tommy just offered me the week in
law and i tell him there's no reason for
you to come out here playing think it's
800 you're getting five yeah
you got three kids
exactly you can't lose 800 because you
want to come in and relive the [ __ ]
glory days he's in new york yeah
he's in new york he's in such a bad spot
really important witness relocation
there he's with us i used to try to
now he's not working how do you not work
when you have three children
i see him on he was working at the
furniture store that's done and then he
got fired from the bar the comedy place
he was too funny for everybody yeah he
was so too funny yeah usually when
you're too funny they actually ask you
to leave
so no it's a it's a [ __ ] working
process you know we've been through a
lot you know whether i'm on rogan's
podcast or somebody's here we always
talk about the storm i'm sure you people
at home sit there and go what the [ __ ]
what are they talking about it's our
training ground guys it's that's our gym
it's our connection to one another
whether it's myself and dice and joe
and wheels and uh wheels with his goatee
it takes him an hour to cut that thing
now
got the goatee put selfies in there and
his selfies are too much i lost 48.8
pounds looked out for me he really did
lose like 150 pounds but i don't need
the selfies i told him i said i'm gonna
unfollow
flexing his arms you can see his tricep
nobody needs to see that [ __ ] abuse
lee how are you feeling
how's it going you ain't high enough
though we gotta eat this jeep yeah your
eyes are still open kill this
[ __ ] shibo julie i don't think
it's monday [ __ ] get it together
here
we got brad this weekend how are you
gonna act okay yeah how are you not
gonna break all weekend
people wait for you did you do stand up
no i got your hotel room for friday
night wow i'm saying you're afraid of
the weekend it's over
and there's edibles companies are coming
down we've got stockings and cape here
see look at you this is over you got a
cape for me i'll come down okay i'm not
[ __ ] around with you would i tell you
today in the text message when i text
when you're going down heavy that's it
no more games no more half pieces of
keyboard shoes we're going for whole
pieces of wednesday night
it's all over you got to get into
briefest shape do you live walking
distance no wall kind of but i'll drive
this is lisa yeah this is the man he
don't give a [ __ ] it's too hot to be
walking i don't know who's going to walk
no i agree
i don't have air conditioning i want
back to have air conditioning i don't
like air conditioning what
and i don't have air conditioning in my
apartment it was one of the big selling
points for me how do you
how do you live
no selling points no rice
no ice cream
ice cream's in ice cream is good any
candy cake ice cream sweets what's all
that [ __ ] [ __ ] air conditioner what
can this never do to you it gets it gets
it look i'm freezing people think i
passed away it's freezing it's in my
bones
i ain't got no iron in my blood 100
degrees outside it's all right 10 pm how
do you sleep at night
no i don't sweat i can listen
you glisten
you have a fan yeah i have a couple fans
i haven't let them go
you still have christopher he moved back
to uh massachusetts are you still in the
same place no i moved i'm like by the
beverly sound how long did you live
there for at that place oh my god me and
chris lived together for like 12 years
and they raised it right now
oh yeah remember that place you live
there too upstairs oh no you're friends
that's right
keith looked there remember that pool oh
god that pool was the best of time it
was nice me and freddie we would go up
there cory
some crazy girl from the
holtzman's building
i forgot her name the black girl with
the hiv not she has like pretty blue
eyes
long brown hair it was that black girl i
took home one night [ __ ] she was blowing
everybody yeah that black girl with the
freckles she was like a light skinned
sister or the other one uh this wasn't a
black girl this was i think her name was
psalm or something
i forget this was a black girl that one
night asked me to give her a ride
to her boyfriend's house and i put the
lights she had open wounds she had open
wounds everywhere oh
guys it was leaking like when they're
leaking
and she was looking for that blow and
her toenails weren't done
you know when your toenails got the
[ __ ] like somebody like somebody
scratching like a ticket like oh yeah
that's gross
you've got a scratch on a lottery ticket
and then when you scratch on the prize
but you leave the sticker around it
that's her toenails look like like
somebody had scratched the middle of it
but had left the [ __ ] artificial
color around the toes she was and i'll
tell you what i love women but once your
toenail polish is [ __ ] up that's where
it ends with uncle joey it's like the
opposite
fetish guy i'm not a [ __ ] i don't want
you jerking me off with your feet i
don't want to suck your feet i just want
your feet to be [ __ ] done yeah i
don't want you to touch me and it's like
your toe has a corn on it ah that could
go through a [ __ ] wall i don't need
that in my life i want your feet if you
don't have that let me know beforehand
and i'll throw you in the yard say go
get your toes [ __ ] bump down
go get that hoof
i have long toes i saw that [ __ ] one
you got like a three-inch [ __ ] throat
her name's robina
you just she drives and shits yeah she's
[ __ ] big she's amazing oh there's
some women i just had to talk to my
acupuncturist into it dr hey man
you don't paint your tongue else because
i never did i go you gotta start i paint
them you gotta paint those [ __ ]
long ones no people don't care that long
they especially guys they see themselves
sucking it my boyfriend laughs at it no
he said that thing's giving me the
fingers so long oh my goodness
what do you think messiah what's going
on with you baby what's up i'm doing
good everything all right what are we
going to eat tonight you want to hide
with me sure let's go get [ __ ] up
tonight i'm already [ __ ] up well let's
get some let's get some of that michael
jackson oxygen what are you guessing
do you eat at the haha that food right
no no no no right next door there was
like a good place they had like pizza
and salads and stuff is it going
that was a while ago it was good really
yeah
it's like at the corner in a strip mall
maybe
i heard that pizza is not bad
yeah it was good it was like good it was
like a kind of healthy ish
but i got it with like the feta and the
spinach and all that shadow
i like the feta sometimes on pizza
yeah it was like a specialty like you
get it
ain't no [ __ ] specialty know what
people smell like
because they're using feather cheese and
[ __ ] that makes your armpits think you
could ask for it with or without no not
in my neighborhood
no no only in l.a i learned of this
fetish
it's really good it's supposed to be
regat sometimes you can get both and bad
against the killer
vegas got good pizza joe's pizza right
across from the hard rock
pizza but even sparrows i'll get a
[ __ ] piece of sparrows in vegas i
don't give a [ __ ] it's all the same [ __ ]
i gotta walk around and go to joe's
pizza and take a cab two pieces of
[ __ ] building it's so good that one
it's a place in vegas
open till four in the morning all right
what would you eat if you had your
choice kind of suck
i don't know how many points you have
left not many like 300 calories 300
that's a slice
yeah but i don't want some slices
no that's one
and a cheese slice is 150 no it's not
a cheese slice is like two to three
hundred no it's not a cheese slice like
this big is a hundred and fifty seconds
that is incorrect yeah it's only six
points weight watches i don't know i
never kept calories it's six it's 60
calories per point so that's 240 [ __ ]
points in the slice
but i went on i had pizza yesterday and
i went on that [ __ ]
my fitness and i put two slices of pizza
i came back with 300 calories
per i don't know i don't know
it [ __ ]
it [ __ ] me it [ __ ] you when you eat
late so i'm trying not to eat past like
how does it [ __ ] that's
if you eat a salad and an apple at night
you're going to [ __ ] out a tremendous
piece of [ __ ] if you eat a pepperoni
[ __ ] sandwich caravel cake
plate oh no trust me you eat a carville
cake you get a game [ __ ]
yeah it'll be fun
but [ __ ] fun will you get a caramel
cake what are you going to eat tonight
i don't don't eat the caramel cake what
about a turkey sandwich
but go to santa monica for dunkin donuts
pumpkin pie is it good i haven't been
there pumpkin pie doughnut is
unbelievable
what's that really when you get home
you'll eat that kind of the rice i'm
gonna try to go to bed i what i what i
want you know
ain't nothing going on in bed
how do you know he's got some mexican
money he's in the house he's in the
house down there he's going to exactly
what are you going to do your house by
yourself
what does that eat
um i don't know i think a couple things
like what i got oh i found some fried
shrimp that are not bad for calorie wise
so i got those i want to try those fried
shrimp what do you do you put them in
the oven yeah but fried is bad right
it's like breaded i don't think it's
it's it's like bread any bacon because i
don't have i don't have a fryer in my
house so how many calories it's like 240
for like 14 pieces of shrimp
so you could i might come home with you
i bought cocktail sauce that's only a
hundred calories for a like a quarter of
a cup
you don't need that much cocktail sauce
wow you got it all figured out i've been
trying [ __ ] calories look at your
little red sox well because i didn't go
to the gym for two weeks so i really
didn't want a game big size go back the
other way yeah it's hard out here you're
a bad [ __ ] at least i'm proud of
you what's hard out here there's nothing
to eat out here i don't know not not
food wise but being a baseball fan
because if you buy the package like i
bought the football package that's only
a couple games a week
like well the first time i moved out
here i did the basketball package you
have to watch a game every night i
bought this because it's so expensive
and they don't show anything well no
that you look there's a sports package
but there's like mlb so you can see
every game and they have 160 games i
can't imagine watching 160 games so i
watch when on espn or something i did it
for hockey hockey was killer this year
you guys like hockey that's the only one
i don't watch every day every day
i love hockey
i don't want [ __ ] no more i didn't watch
football yesterday culture
and last night who was the sunday night
game chicago one chicago came back 49ers
uh 49. why not he's ain't that tough
anymore huh a bunch of these kills they
were beating them they were beating the
[ __ ] out yeah a bunch of the younger
quarterbacks aren't doing that great
like rj3 god just got hurt again broke
his ankle i think sure
it's amazing i don't know anything about
sports how [ __ ] sad is that i thought
you did no for 30 years it was my life i
don't have [ __ ] time to sit there
anymore
how can you [ __ ] watch a game when
you have to write a joke or
i think you write a joke during the game
i feel [ __ ] look at things
i feel so bad about doing anything you
know like when you watch tv like that
you're like there's something i could be
doing you know so yeah no i don't i only
watch like espn i like to watch those
hbo shows i watch boardwalk
but if i i don't might not make it every
week so like sometimes it gets backed up
and i'll see it
i like this
video shows
oh yeah i watch all that i love that uh
also the news one jonath what's his name
oh last week tonight oh i [ __ ] love
it i haven't seen it yet because he gets
mad at me because i'm hbo
what's wrong with you it's expensive no
[ __ ]
i don't have health insurance i have hpv
there's a guy that went and bought six
shrimp for 200 calories yeah area
get hbo get hbo because again what are
you gonna do how you gonna [ __ ] live
you see this with a mexican chick she
wants to watch hbo yes
they have hbo latina come on you know
get it together and where you please
what are you saving 20 bucks
15 [ __ ] bucks
it's 15 minutes [ __ ] bucks yeah but
it adds up who gives a [ __ ] so there's
uh so this is [ __ ] barnacles what's
that for the glasses so this cocktail
sauce well the [ __ ] that
gets looked upside down
because even though you clean it it goes
into your pores yeah so after a while
the [ __ ] that starts breaking the spokes
start sticking to the other thing you
create it
you don't see if you get steam clean
or some chick like cat tongue with your
[ __ ] or something like that and you
don't like your [ __ ] being licked huh
no very strange have you ever had your
[ __ ] not that's why you don't like it
no let me explain something to you if
you get your [ __ ] you'll be a
different [ __ ] man if i wasn't in a
relationship oh i would never let
anybody do that oh my goodness an irish
girl they know how to lick your ass
though oh they open that [ __ ]
oh no and then they squeeze your balls
like one of those bicycle horns
it's a [ __ ] party a bicycle one time
they squeeze that [ __ ] and they
suck that [ __ ]
when you hear that your [ __ ] is
tremendously and your dick's getting hot
and you don't know what to do you have
an anxiety attack you know what your
[ __ ] smells like you let someone like
that if i washed it correctly
like a [ __ ] thing you pull that
[ __ ] out you take that hot water
thing you put in your [ __ ] yeah you
just keep watching pulling cleanse and
you're hearing
like you're fingering like something
yeah [ __ ]
that's a ghetto calling clan oh he's
[ __ ] amazing mama knows that she's
got to stick that tongue in your [ __ ]
muffler
you wouldn't know what to do
no it would not you would have you would
be would have a nervous breakdown if a
chick was sucking your pipe
went down picked up your nut sack
tickled them a little bit sucked them
and then just look at them look at how
he giggles
that sounds terrible no it's not
terrible
no it didn't freak you out the first
time it happened [ __ ] though oh yes it
did why would it freak out first of all
cold tongue i think i'm 450 there's no
such thing as a cold tongue i mean was
she even ice cream first no no i had a
friend who was a [ __ ] and he said his
[ __ ] friend had a cold thought
that their mouths are cold when they
suddenly dick that's what he told me but
i'm 51 years old only two girls are
tonguing my [ __ ]
i don't like it either lee but when it
happens you know what's happening
it's like i go out looking for it what
does that mean when it happens you know
what's happening when somebody's got
that tongue up your ass you know what's
happening and you're looking up at the
ceiling and then making that noise like
they got their tongue up your ass
because when somebody has their tongue
up your ass they make a certain sniff
noise like
like they choke him but not really you
know what i'm saying what do you do when
they're going for a kissling
you kiss him you look at your own
[ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] you're all
going to wash your face the same way
yeah what the [ __ ] is what your problem
is you're too uptight
if you don't start taking this girl to
the hoop
she's gonna leave you for a [ __ ]
attorney in two years that pulls her
hair and
calls her a dirty animal and [ __ ] like
that you know what i'm saying you're
over there being nice to her you should
have taken out to a dirty hotel and tied
her up and left her there and gone to
the comedy show then came back and
whipped it and called her a dirty
mexican and kicked her in the side
and then [ __ ] her like zapata
like how how is vivos about the [ __ ]
mexican chick that mexican chick they
want to run before they get [ __ ] what
was the last time you chased this chick
this is true do you have a leash she's
mexican you don't chase her at all
and tell her immigration you don't chase
him and [ __ ] like that flash your badge
the [ __ ] is wrong with you you're over
there how are you gonna make it tonight
let me put it on no you gotta [ __ ]
turn around and lick your [ __ ] and
once she sees the stars then she'll
repay the favor once she's laying there
and spanish music is playing today
then she'll say [ __ ] it i'm gonna lick
these last hole back
but you're over there making love to her
with flowers and rubbing her down yeah
like a half a fact you can't who said
anything about that pull a hair and say
listen you little [ __ ]
green card
[ __ ] it's all over for you too
how [ __ ] you agree jewish style
i think connor mom doesn't speak english
who gives a [ __ ] and you go and show you
a mama dick what was the last time you
did just take out that little jew rat
and show it to my mother you speak
spanish
uh no they [ __ ] about you
this [ __ ] guy was thinking of taking
a class what do you think if i take a
class on monday nights
i said just watch telemundo you're not
taking no [ __ ] yeah why'd you tell
him one though you're gonna take that
you gotta grab her next week by the
throat are you taking a class get a
rosette of stone stupid yeah get rosetta
stone let's kill her
wait take her by the throat pick up on
the throat and put her against the wall
oh my goodness until this week we ain't
making [ __ ]
crepes it's you dick all weekend long
that's it
what's what's for dinner due date what's
for breakfast you dick what's for lunch
jude dick is the only thing on the
[ __ ] menu this weekend then she'll go
home and she'll tell her i don't know
what got into him no he's just dick is
everywhere
he's he's a different man he's crazy
he's not the same i might leave him
shooting juice sperm all over him
i like it leigh you're right she
look at eleanor if you think if you're a
nice style one she's going to stay you
got to go no
that's what makes us think
you don't want to stay because you give
them flowers what do you want to stay
cause you're a [ __ ] savage league i
like animals
so you eat a [ __ ] but you don't you're
not curious about what goes on their
[ __ ]
do you sniff it do you ever
put some nose to that [ __ ]
no i don't i'm not scared of it but no i
don't really you gotta smell one no next
month that's your homework assignments
when you eat a [ __ ] you're gonna go
deep and report back to us on monday
night oh no what her ass smells like
that's never going to happen have you
even smelt it
oh probably and what you smell like
yeah no no no no no no no no i haven't i
haven't gone in i'm just saying i'm
probably smelted did you smell it just a
little bit no put your whole nose in
there no no no oh my god i wanted to
stay i didn't i didn't die didn't do
that that's your homework assignment
this week next sunday you gotta say
you're you're 26 years old you got to
smell somebody's ass
you're 26. i love you to death i love
you to death if you're my son i'd be
giving you the same advice because your
life's going to change once you stick
your tongue up a woman's [ __ ] once
your tongue goes an inch up there and
you see how they squirm for their life
they start stuttering and [ __ ]
tell them i'm i'm excited about this i'm
just thinking about the son who's being
told that she starts dating your
daughter oh no the first time you got a
tongue up your ass how did it change you
did you even know it did change me i
never understood it and i and i turned
into a different i turned into a woman
there's one telling you no there's no
such thing as puberty this is this
[ __ ] looking like changing put him on
his stomach he'll [ __ ] from behind
and then on the way as you're pulling up
yeah really get into that [ __ ] ass
like that
and make that noise yeah you got to get
all the way in there you got to feel the
spokes you got to feel you got to feel
in there you got to feel one of those
[ __ ] lumps
something that you know what i'm saying
they always got lump in their ass so was
tremendous i love it
so gross i'm definitely not telling my
mom about this product
i don't get this no more you know i love
your people at home it's monday night
what do you want to talk about [ __ ]
the government you know
thank you yeah it it is what it is lisa
yeah eleanor's here what the [ __ ] else
do you want it's monday [ __ ] night
september 15th have you thought about
that have you thought that half the
[ __ ] month's over and you're sitting
there [ __ ] around have you gone to
get your christmas club yet
oh boy have you signed up for christmas
club yet because christmas is around the
[ __ ] quarter that's the most
important thing all right
how high are you i'm [ __ ] high but
i'm aggravated we gotta end this off
with a [ __ ] bang let me get a little
reading for our sponsors here okay let's
start the night off with honor i love
these [ __ ] why because it's not
minerals and supplements it's it's life
optimization you get the best out of you
whether you want to get your mind the
cardio you want to be the best that you
can be like the foo fighters said you
want the best of you understand me go to
honor.com see what they got whether it's
the [ __ ]
strong bone alpha brain alphabet which
is their trademark 100 guaranteed on the
[ __ ] alpha brain understand me who
gives you that even if you eat half the
bills we don't even want the other half
we'll send your [ __ ] money back it's
going to change how you think
protein
hemp force the chocolate delicious
enforcer i see vanilla [ __ ] delicious
also
why are you being a mutt
stop being a [ __ ] mutt go to
honor.com see what they got they got
ropes they got [ __ ] kettlebells
but i'll get you ten percent off on
minerals and supplements go to the box
and press in church
c-h-u-r-c-h
and get ten percent off your next order
on it also they have to stay on the
program you have 20 10 off every month
it comes directly to your door you don't
have to order it you don't have to do
dick you understand beyond that great
it's it's it's health optimization as
they call it
in many circles
number two let me read a good one to you
dollar shave club all right are you a
member or not is there anything else to
buy worse than buying raises you got to
go to the [ __ ] store you got to stand
online they got them in a [ __ ]
plastic fork a [ __ ] plastic fortress
they're gonna cost you 25 bucks you
don't need that [ __ ] go to
dollarshaveclub.com
for a few bucks a month dollar shave
club delivers great razors right to your
[ __ ] door that the plan starts at
three dollars a month signing up takes
two minutes sit back and watch the
blades arrive like [ __ ] clockwork
there's no membership fee there's no
commitment there's who gots and there's
a money back guarantee you got nothing
to lose by trying so do me a favor stop
going to the [ __ ] store and paying 30
more for [ __ ] shitty razors go to
dollarshaveglump.com
church that's
dollarshaveclub.com
church
c-h-u-r-c-h to get your dollar shave
club sent right to your [ __ ] door
okay that's how we do it i don't know
how many times i gotta tell you i've
been telling you the same [ __ ] broken
record for months and you're still using
that piece of [ __ ] with the lights and
the aloe stripped and all that [ __ ]
you're spending too much money do me a
favor cut this [ __ ] uncle joe he'll tell
you [ __ ] lee he don't shave he wants to
be fidel jr [ __ ] that [ __ ] sucker go to
dollarshaveclub.com
church that's how we do it and while
we're on it why [ __ ] around all right
listen you're sitting there you're
paying too much money you're paying too
much money for [ __ ] cable you're
paying too much money for everything if
you think about it let me save you some
money go to huluplus.com and watch shows
on your stay on your [ __ ] schedule
right you probably heard of hulu you can
watch it on anything and hulu is so much
more you can watch it on your roku smart
tv apple tv xbox pretty much any
streaming device you own go to hulu plus
to watch tremendous [ __ ] programming
niche programming criterion collection
animated kids originals you can watch
hulu plus anywhere anytime and you know
what it is
what 7.99 a month oh my god wow 7.99 a
month and that's what you get for me
you're saying joey i get the same deal
on the commercial but guess what
i'm giving you two weeks for free
i'm the [ __ ] arm because that's how i
roll [ __ ] so go to huluplus.com
slash joey slash joey j-o-e-y get 7.99 a
month for original programming you can
watch on your time you can binge watch
shows they've got a ton of shows revenge
mistress the mindy project brooklyn 99
tendon ugly [ __ ] betty all those
shows for 7.99 a month
but i'm giving you two weeks for free
go to huluplus.com and press in joey in
the box and get what lee two weeks for
free all right and 7.99 a month and also
to one of the better things out there in
the market i try them all hit esigs.com
if you're looking to quit smoking they
got 0 8 16 and 24 milligrams to quit on
your own pace this is the best easting
on the market 1200 guaranteed pop pops
1200 online that's amazing
puff the [ __ ] magic dragon can't sink
these [ __ ] you understand me
hateysticks.com go there right now
either get the cigar or get one of the
nicotine cigarettes or one of the
non-nicotine singers and get what and
get twenty percent off we use the
coverage joey's church joey's church
twenty percent of them had
this is the cigar next to all you're
going to get a cigar they're going to
tell you to go outside but you bring
this and you [ __ ] stump
they don't know who they're dealing with
you understand you sit there and you
puff on this [ __ ] denim
tremendous headysticks.com hulu plus
dollar shave club and honest.com go
there right now
i don't like ranch eats do you know you
don't eat ranch so many people see ranch
they put ranch on people no no no no no
she doesn't she doesn't dip with the
wings but she did she doesn't she just
has the hot sauce
she's mexican they don't put ranch on
pizza i saw oh no that's terrible who
does that a lot of people do that it's
these new [ __ ] jokes i got no respect
at their house
the parents never told don't do that
i'll smack it i'll cut your head off
[ __ ] ranch pizza you [ __ ] maggots
don't ever do that around me you dirty
[ __ ] you put red crushed pepper
or garlic right
oregano some parmesan parmesan cheese
very nice
very funny that's it red pepper cheese
[ __ ] strong you know what i'm saying
kerrigan thank you very much for coming
where are you at these next few weeks uh
we're vegas we go to vegas uh thursday
through sunday at the hard rock hotel no
just this week and then back here do a
couple gigs around town and then off to
australia
website they can go see you i'm doing
i'm getting my website done right now
thank god
for three [ __ ] no i just started it
because i don't know anything about
computer i grew up in a typewriter
[ __ ] cold hey the [ __ ] air
conditioner's on here
it's isis oh my god it's isis that's
[ __ ] isis
uh yeah um so yeah there uh but the
thing will be up soon the kids working
on it right now what have you been how
long have you been doing comedy by
itself
without waitressing without
without a day job four years i'm very
proud of you it was scary at first oh
you have no [ __ ] idea you have to
take a chance and dig deep and believe
already yourself don't you yeah because
i was like
back pay on rent [ __ ] like that like he
would let me skip like
that god willing i'm just to be thankful
yeah because he's a good guy with this
place i live now it's not like a
corporate ship it's like an individual
owner and so he was cool as she is like
take your time when you get caught up
hey man people don't work with you like
that
that was hard so we've talked about the
struggle of being a comic at first and
just
telling yourself one day i'm not going
to do this job no more
yeah
well i got fired so it fired you from
the store no no no not the comedy store
i left the comedy store to marry
dice
you married dice i was engaged today
okay and then i left the store
and we got engaged and then freddie
passed away
and then that just [ __ ] me up 2005
yeah
and then that just
that ruined me
big time and then my grandma passed away
like 30 20 days later
and then
like for a whole year i felt like i was
just out of touch like everything and
then i left andrew or we broke up
and uh
we stayed friends obviously and then i
started working on the one woman show
because freddy used to say to me you
should be doing stand-up you guys went
to acting class together acting
everything yeah but he was always saying
you should be doing stand-up you're
funny you should be doing stan i'm like
no
i'm not a stand-up dominance is stand up
bill burr's is still i'm a jackass you
know you know what i mean like that's
crazy talk but now it's like i get on
the same stage with these people i've
gone up before and after bill burr and
been a mess
because he's like one of my favorites
so it's a and dom
i've never had to follow you yet it's
it's really amazing
he did this
that he got sick and tired of watching
you know yeah he said one day
so you feed people at home dog it starts
your life takes you on weird [ __ ]
avenues sometimes and even though it's
late it doesn't matter it's never late
look at this [ __ ] guy over here look
at this [ __ ] kosher [ __ ] little
pink chick jew how cute what did i do
without this [ __ ] look i'm
stoned to the girls you really are proud
of you you know uh
you live your life hearing how rough
this is and how tough and how you yeah
and then i just see you make the
transition it just
lets me know that there's still savages
left in the world what's so funny is
that for you was freddy you know i was
friends with freddie
but for me it was maryland every time i
go to the store i think about them me
too for two or three minutes and they're
probably looking down at us and their
dad said something that
this is my computer at home this is my
computer right here this this four
inches
right here in the cubby hole
i have glasses there because that's what
people do okay they have glasses that
they change every monday for the spirits
oh i see what you mean yeah
glasses there i only have two
and i have pictures of dominic speciale
a kid who died sophomore year
a picture of anthony balzano a kid who
died in the eighth grade
i got a picture of dan regal who died in
1999 it was probably you know 30
something
i picture my mom
i have a picture of my friend's kid that
died
she graduated high school on a friday
she died on saturday
in the car
and i have all their pictures and the
first thing i look at always
at some part of the movie on the
computer i always look over there
and i do the day for them
yeah yeah yeah i was telling lydia then
i wasn't busting these balls
if you go to any of those five people i
mentioned and wake them up out of that
casket and say will you ever watch espn
again they'll go never again i'm gonna
live my life yeah i got a second chance
you know yeah yeah and i always think
about them i look at them and i go if
they had a chance to come back would
they sit at a desk all day on a [ __ ]
computer
[ __ ] no no they wouldn't so we have one
thing like my thing and even from
maryland is to hold her dream up in a
way yeah to do what she couldn't do
today you know
maybe it was to write a joke maybe it
was to
and with maryland it wasn't as much
funny as
you know i think god puts people in your
lives
marilyn was there the first that i did
in l.a she stayed my friend
she always gave me a little advice
and if i tell you something that today
all the advice she gave me came true
she was the one that told me she had the
cancer i went to her house on a sunday
and she became really religious once the
cancer hit her she was always very
religious yeah because what that that
was our connection
certain things up for land she gave that
was our favorite thing yeah all the time
it was really hard for us you know she
used to talk about heidi griffin doesn't
like crucifixes yeah that he's the devil
and all this [ __ ] and one day when she
was about that a lot of people know
that's not people knows right before she
was going to die went to her house one
sunday montoya was there filming her
to make a special about her dying or
something
and she was talking about that when she
goes back to the county store she's not
going to curse
because every word that comes out of
your mouth you have to be responsible
you have to be responsible
and then that same thing suddenly
distracted her
and she looked the other way and she
goes oh by the way
you got to stop doing cocaine
and she looked at me in a way that was
[ __ ] crazy like it was just like wow
okay
and maybe
it took me maybe six weeks after that to
quit doing blow
but the way she said it to me she was
giving me a message from somebody yeah
like somebody told her oh you have to
tell him yeah and look it all turned
down i'm here with you i'm not dead yeah
beautiful two-year-old daughter at the
house my wife is happy
i'm responsible for this mess that mort
over here
who i love
he's a mesophenol
but it's amazing that that advice
usually when people tell you to get off
cocaine you just look at them and go
[ __ ] yourself right that was the first
time i looked and i said done
it was the way she said yeah and for you
was freddy you know you were freddie
with ty you know the baby in my pocket i
never performed without him he's always
in my pocket how [ __ ] crazy is that i
always keep freddie in my pocket so for
me the comedy store was also about that
once i went off on jeff that day and i
walked outside and dyson johnny sanchez
was looking at me weird
like this [ __ ] is really crazy
i was like i'd give that and it was
marilyn laughing the whole way oh yeah
and uh that's what the comedy store has
always been to me it's always been like
a i got this crazy bond you know i was
pulling away and i was stuck there to
make the left yeah down that street to
make the right
to make the other left to get back on
laurel canyon oh yeah yeah yeah okay and
i was looking at that building i can't
imagine that street without that
building uh-uh and they're taking house
of blues down so we get our
our view back
i don't know what they're going to put
there it's like the type of office
building probably
it's just amazing you never forgot
freddie and i don't know if he's not
martina so there you have it
that's why they're latinos special
to uh many of people i love you guys in
eleanor thank you very much for coming
on thank you guys follow eleanor on
twitter what's your handle ej carrigan
ej [ __ ] kerrigan he just follow
on facebook i don't know
and follow lisa on twitter what is it
the flying jew no just lisa and i love
you guys don't forget this weekend i'm
at the brea improv
thursday the 18th friday 19th and
saturday 20th two shows friday and
saturday but next weekend we're taking
it back
to where the devil got [ __ ] in the ass
and [ __ ] pepper sprayed new york city
yeah the gotham comedy club 11 45 both
friday and saturday nights
tickets are still on sale shut the
window yeah we're gonna ustream lee into
the [ __ ] green room
television there but i love you guys
thank you for watching the monday night
late night podcast and for you people
tuesday morning have a [ __ ] great day
when you're listening to this stay black
and stay beautiful stay proud
now the show's over don't forget to sign
up for your free trial of hulu plus hulu
plus lets you binge on thousands of hit
shows anytime anywhere on your tv pc
smartphone or tablet
support this podcast and get an extended
free trial of hulu plus when you go to
huluplus.com joey or go to joeydiaz.net
and click on the hulu plus banner and
don't forget to sign up for
dollarshaveclub.com get high quality
razer center door every month for a
fraction of what you pay at retail now
go to dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash church or just go to
joeydiaz.net and click on the dollar
shave club banner so it's also sponsored
by onyx.com use codeword church to get
ten percent off on things like alpha
brand new mood from duck immune
uh this and lastly the show is sponsored
by hit ecigs.com use code word joey's
church to get 20 off of awesome vape
pens the proof is in the e-cig better
tasting longer lasting
you